[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm oh
we missed it oh
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the magic
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby it's
source
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome we are here it's that time
speech has Championship the round of 16
I'm here with Jeffrey Zhang Chef Jeff
I'm feeding Master James Canty the third
year and we're bringing you a big match
Jeff what do we have playing today
well first of all hello candy hello
everyone uh candy it was a pleasure
getting a chance to commentate on your
all your imscc games thank you but I
think this is our first time
commentating together uh so I know you
love to bring the energy I'll do my best
to reciprocate and yeah let's go we'll
have fun let's have some fun man that's
it so everybody what's at State guys
there's a lot of money on the line lots
of games lots of fun lots of prizes
right and of course the accolades of SCC
Champion here Main Event price fools a
hundred thousand dollars the winner gets
two thousand plus the split um of the
additional 2000 based on one percentage
and the winner advances to uh the
quarterfinals so the matchup today is
gme Karu versus David paravian all right
so I'm excited about that man there's
gonna be some heavy hitter stuff today
what do you think about David's chances
yeah it's gonna be tough I mean
we just saw uh Wesley fend off the late
rally of norterbeck and this is our
final match-up of the quarterfinals so
one more ticket up for grabs
it's yeah I mean no doubt uh
overwhelming favorite
is Hikaru but David he's gonna try his
best I know he can be very sneaky
himself yeah of course so you can't you
can't uh like have David out
you can't knock David out you really
can't the reason for it is I remember
seeing men he took down men of course
newly men to GM but he's already been
there for a while right but he took out
men it was very very impressive to see
that there but uh there is no Hikaru as
we know Hikaru being the best to ever do
this I mean he's won SEC four times
Jeffrey four-time SEC champ
I mean just ridiculous yeah defending
champ if that wasn't impressive enough I
know he's also has 40 title Tuesday
Saturday Tuesdays on his belt so just
ridiculous stuff he's been dominating
the online platform uh for like a good
15 years now yeah a good 15 years right
all the all the Platforms in fact uh
with that being said so it's a lot of a
lot of fun I think it's going to be um
hopefully not a blowout right that's
what uh the predictions were saying like
everybody like 98
Hikaru here so if you guys think Hikaru
is going to win let's get some energy in
the chat Ricardo let's get some energy
in chat for David too as well so
yeah I saw earlier on
209 people I think uh predicted David
per avian to advance well I I admire
that bravery I'm not sure it'll be
rewarded uh so we'll see but it is very
very admirable yeah of course uh if we
see that happen of course something's
gonna happen it's gonna be all over the
all over the Internet guys so of course
the format here is a 16 player knockout
if you didn't know the players will
score points across three time controls
until the time runs out um tie breaks
will be four games of one minute with
one second intro increment one second
bonus and the armagedding with the
bidding so these formats are are
strenuous very long you need a lot of uh
stamina there Jeff
for sure and all the players here I
think focus on both their uh chess but
also physical shape I know that Magnus
is the reason why he's the best he
specializes in that subject and as you
said very very long match you play
90 minutes of five minutes six to eight
minutes uh of three and then finally the
bullet so you gotta Master All Phases of
the time control and uh keep your level
throughout who do you think is going to
win in each section Jeffrey I'm not
putting you on a spot right now Chef
Jeff but who do you think is going to
cook up in each of these uh time formats
well it is going to be very very hard to
go against the car in any of these I
think David's best chance though is
having a good strategy in the opening I
think as a sizable Underdog which he is
the onus is on him to have you know done
his due diligence uh before the match
come in with some good opening prep try
to get Hikaru off guard Maybe
get some openings that he feels
comfortable with and uh try to go from
there well that sounds like a great plan
Jeffrey all right to what did Mike says
Ty say until you get punched in the face
but secondly here we got to see what
smarter chess says about these the this
matchup today we like to prove them
wrong of course so smarter chairs as you
see 95 percent win probability all of
everything is going to the man to miss
the legend himself David is the huge
Underdog number 16 going against the
number one 22 uh or 22 and you see that
22-6 wow Jeffrey that's a lot bro that's
a lot of points man that is a lot seven
two seven two and eight two being
predicted by smarter chess
that is uh that is a lot to overcome and
it is honestly quite hard to dispute I
know that they haven't played the most
uh over the world I don't think they've
ever played but Head to Head online
Hikaru leads 11 to two I believe so that
is pretty significant and has something
to do with these predictions yeah it's
actually going to be very scary for
David Arabian here but of course I think
he just has to put the emotions to the
side and just play the board right I
mean we've been fine gold actually
taught my coach one long time ago said
this thing never forgot it right you
just play the board that's easier said
than done when you are facing Hikaru
Nakamura but you know play the board I
think it takes a little bit of pressure
off
for sure yeah he as I mean you mentioned
pressure he has absolutely no pressure
going in he knows that he is not
expected to win this match and I think
what he has to try to do here you know
just try and let Hikaru know you know
he's he's gonna be in the rearview
mirror try to hang around as long as
possible and uh if he gets an
opportunity try to strike
and here and of course this is what the
community predicted SEC record contest
this is what you guys said total
brackets 14
000 896 and 209 over here of course uh
for two percent and 98 predicted to win
is Hikaru at 98 right seed number one
versus c16 guys it's all there uh David
has a lot of work to do everything's
looking like it's going into hikaru's uh
favor here Jeff
yeah huge disparity there um I did jump
the gun a little bit I mentioned the 209
people once again yeah I commend you uh
I was not as Brazen myself I don't know
about you but how is your bracket
looking by the way oh mine is already uh
uh busted there of course I had Gary
going through but of course r b sparring
right the kid is a monster so he came in
there and just did what he had to do but
he needed that from the cgc too as well
there but uh of course whoever wins this
match is going to place LeBron aronian
of course is what I like to call him um
in the next match there was going to be
absolutely epic so it's either going to
be Hikaru or David as you they're set up
and they're ready to go we're just kind
of waiting now the boys are ready
they're on cam
right and uh and we're gonna see some
great chess here right so the rest of
the bracket though Jeffrey
well first of all yes sir and B Spartan
and LeBron are running I love those
nicknames what do you got for uh for
David and Hikaru anything
yeah yeah
I'll let you think about it I'll let you
think about it but uh yeah I mean look
around the bracket here we see Elite
names everywhere you look
um okay obviously car and madness don't
need any introduction but these other
guys ding nehal as you mentioned uh we
just saw Wesley Advance himself that's a
massive date against mvl which is going
to be a thriller and then I mean okay
Fabiano and Magnus too so just
everywhere you look it's it's amazing
yeah nihal and ding that's going to be
amazing I think ding is uh people keep
people who never like they always count
him out for some reason but forget that
he was number 22 in the world at one
point over 2800 right still a monster
and just kind of under the radar that's
a scary place to be under the radar
monster that doesn't come out you know
unless it's a dark outside right ding
Lorraine is very strong to face and then
you also have a LeBron aronia here
Hikaru on the other side and you got
Carlson right Carlson is trying to take
it away from me Carly if he car makes it
to the final with that four
um sitting on four championships fcc's
for me cargo here so it's a lot man it's
gonna be a lot of great chess here I'm
excited to see and you also get lessons
from here and I always like to do this
commentary here of course because you
get to learn from these guys really get
kind of free lessons in a way if you
aren't you're just not watching it the
right way oh yeah ton I love the part
where you mentioned free lessons it is
completely free for everybody we have
such a luxury we're so lucky to be able
to watch all these great players fight
in the SEC just tune into chess.com and
you get everything absolutely right as
you see the boys on screen a car with
the fresh cut David too as well he got
the little haircut remember do you
remember was that did you see the twirl
match the that was oh the twirl yeah
guys you remember that yeah he cut his
hair
goodness
already starting oh no he with the
disrespectful exactly I would feel I
would feel absolutely disrespected yeah
yeah I mean maybe he thinks he's still
uh playing his disrespect speed run here
but this is something that he I believe
he opted for in the St Louis Blitz and
he played it against me too and it
worked so don't be fooled by uh by this
approach the problem is that it hurts
when you lose to this you're like really
mad like
prepping I was in the lab I was prepping
for hours and A3 move one ouch right you
see the smile there actually from from
uh David there so in this position so
far this looks like some type of a
reverse night or faction indeed indeed
yes slightly unusual Retreat here you
often see that Knight going to B6
instead but Knight F6 certainly very
playable as well and I think David just
wants to yeah he wanted to play C5 so
that's why Curry played B4 to stop that
in his tracks absolutely with the bishop
B2 putting some pressure on the E Pawn
the bishop usually will go to E2 it's
more of the positional Knight horse in
the reverse that you will see with of
course the D5 square but in this case it
would be the D4 Square which is already
underwise control you can play D4 at
some point it's actually a really nice
reverse night over here the Knight to D2
pressure on the C file as well not
really stopping C5 do have to figure out
what to do with this bishop though
Jeffrey maybe something like a uh a uh
route this way that takes a lot of time
yeah I agree with you I mean normally
the bishop will just sit on E2 wait for
it uh for its day later on but I think
it does look very reasonable for her car
he's got a Tempo up but B5 incredibly
interesting approach here I think his
idea is to follow that up with A5 right
a fixing the pawn as you see in like
in-game's hero what they call as a pawn
freeze one will stop too so this is
actually very nice B5 A5 trying to
attack the weak pawns here so what do we
play here Jeff we just go this should be
two anyway
certainly I mean certainly The Prudent
developing move Hikaru already with his
facial expressions I was Danny were here
to identify which one that is but I
think yeah I think Hikaru might be
considering the move d3d4
counter-attacking both in the center but
you also threatened to take on B5 with
the tempo
um oh D4 so D4 maybe D or ed5 or ed4 and
Bishop B5 C6 there's also some 94 in
there weirdly in the second exchange
probably not enough there he's not fully
developed yet B5 move stops and thinks
Hikaru in the think tank very nice yeah
crucial mode this could get very spicy
and he does play this on a board foreign
so now that line that you were talking
about I think 84 Bishop B5 as you said
94 probably not enough you give the
exchange but after C6 I think I just
dropped back Bishop D3 and just chill
and put the Bishops on the diagonal here
I actually had a very strong game
against the international Master
recently it won I was I felt Hikaru
asked I did play like the Knight F3 B3
system over the board game it was very
nice when you get this going it's just
it's it's how do you get these type of
positions right out of a Larson system
it just is insane to me but I can
definitely see this after Bishop B5 C6
Bishop D3 publishing and having the
Bishops just do their thing on this side
of the board D4 on the board Arabian in
the thing yeah and D4 is an extremely
typical break in the naidorf and he's
sitting here with an extra Tempo plus he
gets B5 off uh with the tempo so it
looks very favorable for a car as far as
I can tell I'm a big fan of it I mean
the bishops get very active and of
course in the night off when you need
the B5 square with topano A6 or at least
playing A6 B5 you've had that already A3
B4 Bishop looks good and we got action
takes takes
Bishop D7 draw back to the house
so there it is yeah
played now D4 is hanging it's double
attacked you can't protect that I guess
David's gonna try and Sack and get some
uh initiative going in another way
that's very nice that's very very nice
in fact yeah maybe you can also do stuff
like Knight to C6 defending right but I
definitely like white I mean obviously
we have E5 in some cases too to be able
to break this up and use the Bishops
this way I have to be careful around uh
for the D file pressure that could be
there but at the end of the day this is
a pretty pretty nice for white I like I
like the initiative that we have I was
looking at a few options here A5 being
one of them I thought also Bishop G4 is
interesting pinning the Knight now A5
don't I just respond here with B5 what
do you think he has in mind he said
after B5 after white plays before right
here yeah okay so maybe it's C6 c6a4
though c6a4 takes takes or C5 yeah C6
play A4 right maybe bishop A4 definitely
an option to keep the heat the knight at
Bay stuck on B8 but yeah you would give
up the B4 square and black could plant
his Bishops so
a lot of options for a cart you can also
take on D4 either before after BC so a
few options yeah yeah yeah interesting
interesting maybe I go B6 intake I just
don't want to develop his piece by
taking that's the only problem oh wow B6
would be very creative with the idea I
guess Knight C4 if black were to capture
oh I was actually just taking on D4 but
we're just gonna take it yeah I was just
going to tape it Knight C4 is very nice
let's see if it's very nice B6 Queen B6
94th then take on default very nice yeah
very very curious moment here both sides
around three minutes he does go a for
your original idea allowing Bishop B4
but you do keep this Knight on B8 for
the moment I might as just get out of
the way too as well the knights on B8
restricted by the pawn this is one thing
you want to do to your opponent's pieces
is restrict them development is actually
lacking for black white is one move away
from castling almost connecting the
Rooks figuring out what to do with the
queen later E5 is definitely gonna be
played at some point indeed yeah if
Black's not careful you go Bishop B4
castles E5 would already be a huge
threat in that position so I think black
has to develops about oh he's going to
try 95 Knight F4 I like it engine says
this is not a move try a new try again
what is that I mean this is like that
looks like a great move though yeah
engine engine is always always scoffing
at other human ideas but it does look
very logical if he provokes G3 then
maybe the follow-up will be Bishop H3
interfering with the castle so not so
clear do you allow Knight F4 here or not
that's a great question that's a great
question I really I mean I really don't
like the Knight on F4 that's just so
annoying there but Hikaru doesn't
doesn't care Knight F4 I guess he goes
Bishop C4 yeah maybe just Bishop C4 and
then we have to watch out maybe Queen F6
but okay that's that's provoking it
there it is Bishop C4 the goal is
obviously putting the queen over here
but also maybe even Bishop H3 ideas at
the right moment oh Bishop H3 would be
in the air but Bishop D4 comes with
Tempo I think I think you do try the
queen of Queen G6 what I really want to
do for black though is develop that in
atom B8 somehow move your Bishop away
maybe also can go Bishop G4 Knight D7
just finish development right and maybe
a nice C5 finished development right
which is a huge thing that we talked
about you he's he is not finishing his
development which means he's basically
two pieces now right now but of course
we don't need it just yet the Bishops
are going to get very active and the
engine likes wise position as a human
standpoint we do as well as we're one
move away from really complete and
development connecting the Rooks Black's
still trying to do that we also have a
pass V Pawn oh yeah if white were able
to consolidate this position like have
no nothing to worry about with his King
then he would just be a clean pun up and
more so that's why David has to try and
cook something up he's gonna try this
bishop G4 maybe bishop G4 yeah 64. I
like it like look at this from a
practical standpoint pieces are on the
fourth rank two of them
everything maybe three though a nice
move removing yourself from the pin and
also with Tempo hitting F7 right hitting
F7 with Tempo very beautiful and he
takes D4 as a movie also have E5 once
again this E5 move is very very like you
can just smell it you know it's there in
the area but it has to be right it has
to be right
yeah and even I'm looking at uh it's not
even easy for David to cover on F7
conveniently like Queen E7 might run
into your idea with E5 already not to
mention white can always pick up D4 and
just have a healthy Pawn
whenever I want oh by the way you do
need to use the time as a piece as well
and David has none of that he has
nothing he's getting low but I mean it's
hard to blame it very very tough
position here he goes Queen D7 but that
takes away the square for the Knight so
it does not look very appetizing
absolutely not of course so two pieces
down it feels like here but we need to
be able to use it the right way you put
E5 still and can with Bishop takes D4
Knight G5 I mean these are all moves so
many good options yeah you can also
rookie one even I was gonna say just to
keep all the flexibility alive but I
think objectively speaking maybe you
just take on D4 here I'm not sure what
the bishop for the Knight
great question uh I really like Bishop
because I want to play E5 ASAP ASAP but
I mean Knight taste is no problem maybe
this bishop E5 there it's great position
for white he might be calculating some
kind of counter play for black along the
lines of Bishop H3 but I don't think any
of that nonsense will work
so but yeah he's just making sure he's
covering the bases doesn't want to get
too long time though down to 40 seconds
and counting definitely both of them low
on time here but this is still a lot of
time for Recaro and you get that one
second increment so this isn't really
well the the the no increment chest that
we're used to playing we have to play so
fast Bishop D4 on the board
E5 definitely a threat
the speech five threatening Queen G4
watch out
and now maybe us actually ages three you
get sad so strong G3 Queen H3 GF I guess
you get away with that Knight on F3 is
covered twice
Bishop F4 is close it's so close and
rookie six is not there I can't go over
k6 either that's funny this Pawn
stopping all the ideas
both kh1 and King G2 seem good and
you've got Bishop D5
Knight of four David down to nine
seconds or just wants to be careful here
E5
whoa wait a second is there Knight of
four still King H1 I don't see anything
but you can't take on E6 which he does
take 76 Bishop C3 two seconds
oh my God I think he's back in the game
here by the way but
he's just got no time gotta make some
pretty moves oh speaking of time Hikaru
two two about the same amount of time
here it takes takes yeah not convincing
by any means got an end game here Rook B
one going after the pawn
84 repeat two very double-edged sword
here in this area 96 yeah and oh the E5
as his B4 he picks this up now his car
seems back in the driver's seat right
very poor attack very very poor very
poor for the slip chat I'll let it slip
H4 H6 take take Chief we have Richie for
you this is I mean it should be winning
should be pretty clean here you're gonna
have two pawns up
uh maybe just yeah remove yourself from
the pin and go from there 94 Knight F5
coming
oh and look at that beautiful all kinds
of matingness hold on there's a oh
Knight of five oh Knight F6 that's it is
Flags but it was losing bit of a shaky
start there from Hikaru but most
importantly gets the job done uh yeah I
mean 1a3 came to fruition maybe I might
uh put that in my repertoire if I can
get these kinds of things
A3 that's just insane bro playing A3
move one and winning it's just you know
insane right A3 A4 we're gonna see all
kinds of stuff here today if that's how
he's doing it first game A3 he can play
anything at this point on Jeffrey
oh yeah and I feel like this is his
match strategy which is just to evade
David's prep just to play real chess not
going to give you any home cooked of any
sort and yeah show me what you got all
right here we go game two is up and
running E4 on the board what are we
gonna go with today C6 look here okay
little Carroll Khan
life I like a car's opening so far he
doesn't go for his normal Berlin so
again sticking to this agenda of
avoiding David's uh prep right he's
gonna probably bring it out at some
point there but definitely going I mean
I think I was very versatile we've seen
him play many different openings here oh
yeah Carol Khan very strong with the
queen of B6 option here C5
yeah I believe this is all Theory I'm
not the most familiar with this line I
tend to yeah I played a queen A5 Queen
A6 myself for black but yeah it's gonna
be slightly uh different looks kind of
like a French actually oh yeah you're a
french guy I say I've played some French
for myself too as well yeah it does
absolutely a great French with the
bishop gone so that's exactly what this
has become now from a Carroll Khan
obviously we do have takes on D4 97
Knight F5 ideas this is very solid for
black
right but do note that this H4 H5
inclusion is favorable for white that H5
Pawn much weaker than its counterpart
can be hit with like a knight of four
and also the G5 Square permanently under
White's control here you never have like
an H6 to kick a piece absolutely there
is some uh some lines with early Rook
h3s you also see this in the Fringe as
well playing G4 once the king figures
out where he wants to go in castling C4
on the board I mean B2 is always
answered with Rook to B1 and taking on
B7 so this is why Queen B2 is not being
played here you can also can only
Queen's almost trapped like Knight C3
Knight B5 stuff
yeah probably the too speculative to
take on B2 but this is a very quick
strike in the center by David saw a
slight head shake from Hikaru not sure
if he feels comfortable in this type of
position yeah I've only studied a little
bit of this Theory here I know Queen A6
when you can like pin it here I've seen
this in theory before
but is he I mean he shook his head so I
guess he's not happy with this but Queen
A6 was Queen A6 looks correct otherwise
you don't allow cd5 shattering your Pawn
structure wait go CD4 but what if cd5 oh
yeah wow wow a little in between move
there Queen B3 wild takes there was D3
now it's something interesting D3 D3 was
interesting there but in any case I
think we're gonna have Queen A4 check
maybe forcing an end game after Queen C6
you take Knight D4 and I think you have
a very slight Edge as white yeah take on
D4 yeah that's correct it's a slight
slight Edge it looks good looks good
slight Edge is white on the edge is
really I mean I guess a little bit of
space and the better Pawn structure on
the queen side Target on the C file yeah
that is the most important thing and one
extra Pawn Island for black doesn't seem
to mean much but it could especially as
you said if you get some uh pressure
along the sea file you also have this
juicy blockading Square on C4 for your
other night
back to C4 very nice F6 I forgot about
that break that's very annoying
aha no no good squares for the bishop
you have to probably drop it on E3
well I still like white because you have
this Knight I mean you're gonna get
You're Gonna Play Knights before at some
point and even though I mean the double
epon's look funny but you're gonna
probably play ef6 at some point and
undouble them
yeah just upon Islands here are pretty
rough one this is all one
two here very solid I guess he's gonna
go for something different so I won at
Night C4 but I think he's gonna play
Knight B3 instead and maybe use that C4
Square for The Rook play Rook C4 double
and uh yeah put the pressure there on
the queen side beautiful I like it
Knight B3 Rook C4 doubling of the Rooks
and just bullying the ball it's a clear
plant very clear plan it's nice to have
a clear plan you can play quickly and
confidently and he's up time right now
this is a pretty nice game for Dave
yeah and I will also point out that the
E5 Pawn does hang but black is not
exactly ecstatic to uh to take it you'd
be left with these really ugly looking
pawns here
um yeah for example I mean 95.95
fe5 like just Knight E4
I don't think uh anybody would be gross
please
yeah this is disgusting he's gonna Zone
to scream please
all right but on the other hand it is
very difficult to find alternatives for
black like what sort of ideas are you
hoping for
is jv7 and actually uh Rook to B8 yet
here this reminds me of uh there's a C3
Sicilian position that you get with the
white side that's similar where you have
some activity that's really all you're
playing for because the pawn structure
is really bad and I think that's what
black is doing just playing for a trying
to get activity but White's more active
so I mean you're not playing for
activity the structure is bad I'm just
kind of holding like this is not the
girl con that you would hope to get for
in any situation of Europe oh no no no
yeah and I think we're going to see an
immediate switch in hikaru's next Black
game The Last move by David Rook HD1
very nice just keeping that Keen stuck
on EA if he were to have castled there
would have been a rook D7 sighting so
ultimately Hikaru does take on E5 but I
feel like white has many Pleasant
options to choose from now
you know what's weird though there's
actually it's very hard to get rid of
the sniper you could about Knight F2 I
guess just get rid of it but this these
pawns aren't restricting a lot of
squares right now yeah they're double
but they're restricting a lot and I
can't take this one just yet
but then again it is a fair point you
always have the Knight F2 idea in your
back pop Pocket removing the defender uh
on E5 but I think you also can just
leave the situation as is maybe just
double here back on C5
I like it doubling maybe pressure the
pawn two versus one good chances over
here very good chances you have to watch
out for a potential and eventual E4
after everything is traded on C5 E4 and
Rook F2 would be very very annoying
very very annoying to face good point
yeah could get concrete there potential
complications could arise I'm also
looking at a way to play this very
slowly maybe magnet style even play a
move like G3 just covering H4 and then
maneuvering the Knight on F3 via E1 to
D3 where I attack everything and also
guard that F2 Square Magnus yes you've
been studying some magnets yeah for Chef
Jeffrey always be out here cooking up
something that's nasty g391 Knight D3
with just a positional grip there and
it's just uh beautiful I love it I'm
definitely just doing nothing's what
kramnik likes to call it doing nothing
but doing it very well is very nice
he's gonna go slightly more aggressive
route here with Knight fg5 align the
bishop takes I don't know if I
understand right I mean okay
right do we take it
I think he has to take yeah yeah
and now how do we yeah I'm looking at
right I'm looking at okay I guess first
of all if you take on C5 you don't want
a live Rook of two so definitely
discount it but there's also a rook D6
move that I'm looking at
over these six so you got your ideas
here Rook C6 right I just want Rook C6
and Android C7 or take a nice nice
the car was a move oh no sir David's
move here rookie six wait Rook D6 is
they're like Knight F2 oh they're kind
of Rook F2 or something reflecting right
you would simplify it uh White would
still be better there but yeah I'm not
sure if I want to let you exchange my
beautiful Knight there on e4
interesting he's trying to figure out
what to say what's wrong with doubling
then I was saying yeah what's wrong with
this move maybe I mean he's just if you
double I thought the idea was great yeah
although I mean you can always take on
C5 there and you would cover
or excuse me three first
also nice and solid
it's hard to find moves for black it's
really hard it is it is your Rook is
stuck on A5 you have to keep the Knight
on G4
basically there are no ideas you have to
wait yeah you have to wait here you have
to wait Rick have five it's almost in
the zoo on position you don't want to
move the Knight and with Rook okay what
do you do like that okay we gotta go you
gotta just play one of those moves okay
oh man that's too funny Rick B8 okay
wait a second so he's allowing Knight
takes C5 now
what is this
exactly yeah I'm not sure why he wanted
to give this up because with the real
kind of Fate you always had a rook F2
and a car yeah he shakes his head I
think he just forgot about that very
poor very very poor right that's just
blunder chat and you see it I mean the
engine thinks that's a fool and 2.3 at
this point from that clean Pawn there
Knight C5
he goes kf7 he's gonna try King G6 at
least
his trick might be some sort of key
stand I don't know well there's another
one what is this give me everything
interesting rookies no that doesn't work
oh Rook G7 km5 E4 check that's what it
is
you skewer and key for you have Knights
I think he's gonna spot it E4 what a
move
will he spot this I mean you can also
play Knight C5 that's probably good
there it is lights out nice put it on a
board boom Rook C4 check first you are
pre-moving it out wow
he just nothing new happened in 986 I
like how he's taking his time here I got
more moves I can take the road wait ah
yeah yeah wait a second but he lied Rook
D6 he did that was kind of why'd he do
that that is insane
yeah
goodness look at hikaru's face like bro
you are you kidding me oh my goodness
bro don't tell me he now he but he's not
gonna lose this you can't lose this
right Jeffrey you can't lose this right
Jeff well this is unreal I mean
psychologically it's very hard to
recover you were just gonna be a rook up
if you took on A6 and now it's a game
wow I mean David can't lose this right
come on no he can't I don't think you
you can possibly lose but maybe it's his
drawn out if you take and take on B3
wow that's that's crazy takes days Rigby
three pushes yeah
can you get your Rook behind the pawn
I'm not sure I mean it's already even
material I think it's a draw yeah it has
to be drawn I mean but the promoter came
from it feels like a lost right you know
completely it does I mean The Rook on
Asics was hanging like I can't stress
that part enough
it was just hanging it was literally
just hanging
literally we could have just taken the
route but that's what happens sometimes
when you look for a good move and you
try to find a better one and there was
not a better one there I mean it
probably was but Knight takes 86 was
just clean very easy simplify yeah the
car effect exactly I mean
just really insane he wanted to simplify
there yeah he he forgot just a sudden
blind spot he forgot about Rook D6 yeah
and yeah now it's very likely going to
be a draw
wow I would have saved probably what I
say yeah game for work F7 the potentium
is definitely drawn here let me just
check check literally everything check
check check
probably five
wait a second maybe you can still push a
little bit rookie five
ah but key six yeah this is clinical
he's got Rook G4
yeah thinking D6 yeah just 15 seconds
before maybe I'm not sure which way you
go both are probably fine
you're gonna take the draw whoa whoa bro
you almost flying you are tripping he
playing around yeah yeah
whoa bro one gift was already enough
yeah all right
that should do it
but sheesh there we go oh man oh man I
got a little scary there
come on bro come are you kidding me it's
what are you doing Jeffrey mess
yeah I mean I still can't get over that
Knight takes A6 was was just a free rook
but wow yeah oh and now H oh wait yeah
oh my God one H3 now H3 goodness sakes
Ace three come on bro can you can we
have a sense of respect here okay Knight
to C6 I don't even know like what is he
gonna do E3 yeah I was wondering about
G4 here here we go here we go all out of
theory
two what you got I think I can play D5
for black
I want to punish punish your uh delayed
grub set up oh for sure for sure you
know he straight disrespect the Earth
lafonte D5 takes Knight D5 and Bishop G2
I mean and at Knight F4 like I'm already
on you I'm literally already attacking
you 97.
spooked him a little bit maybe E4
yeah he's gonna maneuver that Knight
around to G6 I guess try and uh
get at those soft squares week one on H4
maybe F4 as well but here what if I play
G5 first of all kicking out that night
well G5 now actually this is nice you
see this a lot of aggressive Sicilians
with G4 G5 my favorite stuff one of my
favorite pawns to push right G4 is about
D4 though after it takes Queen takes
okay
makes sense now that the Knight left
yeah I think you'll no but if he comes
back we need three check followed by G5
and a potential Knight D5 might be an
issue very nasty very nasty push back
there
this is really enough now fine and I'm
gonna cast I mean again I really like
akara's position after this H3 I'm not
even gonna lie it's because I think he
just this was probably an unnecessary
move and all it takes is one tempo right
and we know that you know that one tempo
thing 97 this was it feels strange now
and you see you can feel what's it
what's about to happen right move the
bishop Castle Queen side push everything
go for mate
that 97 perhaps just a little bit too
passive and the car Johnny on the spot
with D4 a great reaction
yeah it looks looks really tough if you
don't play Knight C6 here I don't really
see another move because I mean Knight
G6 would just run straight into G5 is
this the new meta he's up a minute on
time a whole minute H3 move one right up
a whole minute and this looks very good
for white as you can just see the
possibilities the options the
flexibility is what we like about his
position
yeah I'm taking notes here like I
struggle to get any sort of opening
Advantage when I'm playing White against
Providence so if H3 Is What It Takes
sign me up
all right that's funny that's funny I
like this D5 move finally just doing
something strike
we take we think aha but I thought I had
the move G5 here because again like oh
G5 no no but Knight F5 there's Queen E5
check so what exactly
you do okay so do you find it's a good
click the move let me see I guess I just
go back to GS gross he plays it too like
look at this but 95 queen queen 25 am I
blind here
am I blind
what am I the engine didn't move though
engine didn't move yeah the engine
didn't move
yeah it is it's extremely crazy right
now huh oh my God Queen E5 Bishop E6 gf6
Bishop D6 maybe traps the queen
you cannot be serious this is disgusting
bro this is disgusting David foundus
What a fine I mean he went from hanging
to finding this David you gotta chill
man you gotta chill bro you got to
breathe that's a move that's this wicked
attack Wicked check Bishop Bishop D6
develop everything trap to Queen that
was beautiful that was actually
beautiful I think you can't miss this as
well oh for sure I mean how could you
not and yeah car spots it now he goes
Queen D3 still should be reasonable
right because once the Black Knight
moves you can win look at David bro he
just Relentless here huh takes well we
just take it and take it what's wrong
with this Jeffrey well I don't know if
that's the best way to recapture the
point I like cd5 a little bit more
because now I don't give many tempos to
Black and I think I want to follow it up
with you for next uh once the nights
come off very nice
takes and a quick Haru looking nice here
we can push forward gotta be with
caution though definitely caution
Bishop's open position and we made some
concessions here and where does the king
go you have to go this way
yeah really nice job by Carl keeping his
composure there after a brilliant idea
from David David will spot some stuff
here Knight F5 was absolutely sick
that was a sick move
but is there any way to keep the
initiative going I'm looking at Knight
C5 but it doesn't really amount to
anything
maybe do we go Queen C4 some nice movies
for looks like a solid Square yeah is
your queen could not be further attacked
and yeah E4 would just be on tap before
A6 maybe A4
simply stopping all your ideas
too I wasn't as sure because Knight D4
correct could hit you but I guess he's
not worried about that at all just cook
weedy one all right all right go back
home
yeah it's fine
so now David's still trying to find more
tricks I wonder okay there is an H4
Square for the night so like let's say
you go Bishop seven E4 Knight H4 trying
find some counter play on the king side
Maybe
that's funny Knight H4 here
but I'm sure David's moved not enough
David's moving it's not enough this is
tough because E4 is coming you have no
center right you have no Center oh not
at all
and you're still here oh yeah I forgot
about that right down a pawn no Center I
mean what is this he's just playing real
chess with him he's just trying to get
positions which is very nice I like the
uh the strategy he's choosing it's just
I just want positions because this is
nothing out of the theory books I'm up
upon got a full Center like this is how
what is this
it's weird GM chess yes can you go H6
for black this is my new idea at least
yeah try and take advantage of that over
extended G Punk get my rook in the game
I really didn't like it but I was like I
mean H6 is possible to try to get the
rook in the game eventually I mean it
was very very strange but it works it
really works H6 Queen E7 he chose okay
so at least now E4 there's Knight D4 I
believe and um could be some tactics uh
on the e-file 94 again
so maybe just like a solid Knight F3
move here for white
or not or B4 what do you mean solid we
played H3 Jeffrey solid what what is
that yeah the car is not in the mood for
for any solid games here yeah it's
nothing solid round here my guy B4
Knight D7 maybe A3
or E4 anyway I mean look at the Menace
it's just wild like there's too many
things going on but it's keeping the
clock very low for David
yes feels like all Queen moves are pawn
moves from mikaru and it's it's working
I mean this there's not much
conversation uh to show for David
h3g4 A3 I mean
the man is just you don't know what
you're gonna get from your Karu now
before attacking the Knight Knight to D7
my hit yo yo you gotta move bro you have
to move he makes him he makes wait a
second how does this work though I can
play either Queen D1 or queen D2 and
there's a double attack on both these
Knights I think we do two oh you're
right yeah 94 obviously I'm gonna play
Queen D4 but it doesn't work so Queen D1
and which one's better and queen D2
there might be a weird beaten 22 maybe
Knight B3 yeah so Queen D1 is safer
right so it's the night now both nights
are hit that's just a piece bro hit the
button I think he's yeah he's exhausted
all his tricks leans back there
a slight rub the hair just not much you
can do right now yeah yeah he can't tour
you see he's trying to twirl us there
look at that he's trying to twirl a fade
yeah let me toward a fade and we toured
a fate
we need five oh and that for another
Bond movie everything it's got Bishop D2
and he's gonna collect the Knight you
know she got up to Bishop D2 and
collected my Rook C1 is even probably so
no no we don't need to he might throw it
in yeah he does I guess I guess okay why
not right yeah throw it in
I think here are queen B3 I just forced
the Queens off you've got Bishop G2
you've also can probably move the Rook
here and then unpin many ways you can
convert castles 95 that's it 95. uh he
takes the pieces for the queen we can
just Castle or Rook G1
well David's still fighting on ah your
car you can see what he thinks of that
all right look at his face really really
we're playing this one now bro that's
what he's saying really come on come on
for that really oh man that is a
Priceless reaction and a girl all right
he's taking his time he's gonna actually
for hikara makes more sense to to take a
sweet time here because I think the
bullet is where he feels the most
comfortable so he doesn't mind letting
some Seconds come off the clock
or t in order to B1 oh that's a make
sure we're not hanging up and crazy here
we did give him a little bit of counter
play but we're fine
C6 is is also hanging here you can
probably just take on H4 first
between C6
why are you smiling bro I can't get
enough of the camera
oh look at his face that was funny
all right David Bounce Back Time
Sicilian for me Carl
yeah that caricon was really good for
David the first time around we see a con
by Hikaru this is not something I recall
seeing but also C3 was that a mouse slip
I think he was I'm looking at his face
to see because I know c4's Theory so C3
he looks like he wanted to play C4
I think yeah yeah a little Shaker maybe
he's from the last game too but I think
this was a mouse club yeah I feel like
he's still rattled from that second game
where he should have obviously won there
was just a full Rook up but yeah he
didn't have the clearest of reactions
but again I've never seen the move C3 uh
right I was like maybe he's trying
something new here right we'll see but
of course C4 uh was the the move he
intended if that if that was indeed a
mouse slip
still a solid position though I mean
probably normal development for Macaro
Knight F6 maybe he'll I'm not sure if we
go D5 or D6 there's your answer
hit E5 now a lot of times you could play
E5 but that's when like pieces are more
developed there's a pawn sack here all
the time let me see Karu like don't do
that right so he takes takes yeah now I
don't need to sack anything very solid
mm-hmm keeping things calm rookie one I
want to play Bishop D6 but that might
run straight into Knight F5 and it's
getting massive complications so
basically seven the conservative uh wave
from a car
I'm definitely filming Queen G4 just to
throw it out there or uh something else
Knight of five does not wait a queen's
somewhere there you go David yeah he's
gonna do it he's gonna try to make yeah
I'm gonna try to make her uncomfortable
maybe Knight F6 he'll play a queen H4
follow that up with some sort of Bishop
F4 ideas and uh look for King side
initiative very nice very nice here
Queen H5 very annoying move we still
have to develop the rest of the pieces
for white so it moves uh maybe Knight A3
C3 Sicilian this is what it feels like
it's some type of elephant where we
trade at the center 92-94
possible
a fan of this move though I do I
actually like David's position I am a
fan of uh the initiative that it feels
like we have practically yeah I mean
that C3 if it was a mouse slip
definitely doesn't seem too bad and here
Hikaru is taking a bit of a think I
think he's deciding between either G6 or
Knight F6 I believe you have to kick
that Queen away oh no it goes Knight of
four four I thought there was I thought
there was like a [__] before in the E6
Pawn is hanging but
maybe it doesn't quite work like there
is Queen C1 check there's also Jesus
yeah yeah and G6 yeah
but he's could be heating up
and he happened it's on the board
yeah now it's time for the calculator
come on bro takes takes takes check
Bishop F1 Queen B2 or maybe just G6 but
I have Queen E5
there's probably a little bit too much
to worry about for white it's like I'm
not sure about Queen's one Queen B2 I'm
not sure about Jesus so I say while
engines just says this is not a move so
maybe is it Bishop takes Rook tape
probably just Bishop takes and I don't
know either Queen's winner G6 yeah check
first just to throw it in okay Bishop F1
[Music]
Knight to C6 okay yeah yeah just develop
the price range yeah okay we're gonna go
back to the game yep yep but in any case
I don't think David can afford to take
on E6 it's just too much to calculate
and it's not clear in any line yeah it's
definitely difficult here the Knight C6
move especially is one that you're you
have to find it
he going right into the line he going
right into it Chad he had to right Rook
takes Queen C1 Bishop F1 Queen B2 and if
he finds Knight C6 he courage is up yeah
you go Queen C1 here wow my place is
first instantly hey let's check in yeah
yeah we got the fair play yeah
look at the fair play over there right
now uh y'all see this y'all see it live
yeah you gotta check for check for
something yeah yeah I think the whole
idea is that Rook d8 is coming next so
White's gonna have to drop the Rook back
assuming uh I assume and then Rook d8
will come your knight on B1 completely
pinned can't sub Rook D1 everything
falls apart oh man this is a wicked
Knight to C6 right like it's just it's
insane
too it's just 96 first like bro
and that took him that took him all of
like five seconds too I mean granted he
was probably calculating on David's time
but still all the more impressive just
to Blitz such a move out so yeah nice C6
so quick there look at him right he uh
in the zone they're playing a little bit
longer you see he's confident David's
still in the zone though thinking he
doesn't seem rattled at all because it
definitely feels like something there
but I mean he doesn't see that we we
have the eval bar here eval Bar says
he's down the piece here and there's no
hope but practically as a human you
still feel like you have some some
chances here you did take on E6 King's
still in the center
yeah I mean I don't see how to create
anything like yeah once again I mean
you're permanently pinned on the first
rank I'm willing to give you an exchange
to get development but like Rook takes
E7 Knight 67 and then what
yeah and then what that's probably what
he's thinking about and then what do you
do like you can't get out and you start
realizing dang this position sucks
that's when you you know that hurts when
you calculate so much and you realize
your position is like sucks
brutal I mean just what a cold-blooded
moment there though C6 and he's stopped
in his tracks
stopped in his tracks
is there a night to see any Fighting
Chance
just don't see it I really don't let me
see what the engine says best move is
Rook E2 before
and F4 and F4 but that's ridiculous
exactly that's ridiculous I mean I'd
rather resign than uh before there right
yeah Rook E2 this is um very very
logical but you also don't have a real
good follow-up it says take on C6 come
on bro come on bro and then I mean I was
trying to do that but again it doesn't
solve the the back ring pin yep
yeah nice C6 Music Stops exactly that
was a mic drop moment nice C6 and it was
silent in the room
totally wasn't David right now he might
have already just given up the game but
he wants to
he wants to collect himself he feels
like he still hasn't recovered from that
game too
play Rook E3 I mean I wasn't even on any
of the moves from the engine so rookie
three
um okay what do we do though for boys
I don't see any problem with leaving
that key in the middle one move longer
yeah you can't I mean look at the pieces
back here all right pin here pin here
clean is ridiculous down here
Carl seems perplexed maybe he sees an
idea after Rook d8
yeah he definitely is look at him what I
just play I just play this I just play
Queen B2 oh there's also Queen B2 oh my
God goodness I forgot about that one
that's why rookie two was yeah it's just
more natural yeah I just want to get
another game real fast just hit the
button bro like and just we get another
game real fast this one didn't work he
plays C3 I think I guess that was really
messed him up too
yeah this is a really rough turn of
events could have been a 1-1 match and
we'll be speaking a whole different I
mean seeing a whole different tune but
yeah looking like three and a half half
uh very shortly
maybe seven
he's trying to keep the queen in there
okay A little trap come on David
come on David trying to muster up some
something it should have six but yeah
after Bishop six you're never ever
trapped here because white can't move
the Knight Lawrence Rook d8 C3 it's all
over yeah it is and he's out and there's
the button yep
there it is
Dave is just cruising right now
come on bro yo you know what this is
what we doing tonight when I stream
tonight you streaming today Jeffrey
uh maybe I mean well if he plays H3 and
A3 the entire match like in all of his
white games I will also that's what I'm
doing today I'm gonna play this tonight
like is this all but it's like A3 H3 in
honor of Hikaru doing this nonsense here
and making it work
and making it work this is insane how do
you keep a straight face playing like
this I'm looking at him I would be
slightly tilted I'm not gonna lie I
really I really will be slightly tilted
because you know you prep for this right
like he had time I'm prepping for your
good openings for your carocons for your
Berlin right for your Queen's Gambit
decline what you like to play on like
move 20. I'm trying to prep for you and
then you come in here and play H3 and A3
every game right and I'm down three
three and a half to a half I'm slightly
tilted I'm not gonna lie I'm slightly I
mean how could you not as David here and
this is the last game before the finite
break he's got to find a way to punish
this extracurricular stuff from uh from
a car out of the gate all right yeah I
mean and it's pretty nice I think uh
icaro has lots of flexibility in the fin
Kettle openings of like the Catalan he
also plays the NIMS of Larson with 60
win rate plus against 2800 competition
um he's very nice with that so the
openings obviously with the fin kettles
or the Bishops he becomes very strong
sharp at King's Indian too as well it
really favors and playing these wild
positions like this David I think
you can probably go D4 again like we saw
in game two so opening the center like
Again David trying to maneuver this
Knight around to g6h4 but it does seem a
little slow yet again
definitely slow but also Knight G6 is
very strong though it is very strong
planning that 9h4 yeah I see you but
it's still I think I can go like 94
Knight D5
so yeah this is somehow became he's like
getting nimso Larson positions with an
early G4 it's like crazy how he's doing
that I mean both of these were like this
with the B3 C4 he gets the bishop out a
little bit further than B2 you castle
and you play D4 and you open up this is
very strange but it's working I'm
starting to understand it H3 most modern
opening Theory that's right Chad that's
exactly right most this is some Modern
opening Theory this is honestly
it's incredible because I think hikara
has a very nice position again like you
could yes play this in a variety of ways
you can long Castle play for your D4
idea you can also play for the squares
with Knight E4 you put the other Knight
on C3 and black doesn't have a safe
Square for that King you're not castling
law you're not living in the center the
moment you Castle short white is going
to bombard you with the potential F4 G5
so this is I mean I don't know what to
say this thing HCG 4 is is this is the
new way Jeffrey just a new wave bro I
don't understand how he's able to get
away with it I don't know I know this is
the new wave you want to see this in OTB
play yeah I got a new one from uh H3 and
uh A3 move one
degree watch out there's a knight of six
and Knight H5 subtle threat here oh
that's a nasty combo actually let's just
show that on the board takes Queen takes
Knight H5 oof nasty picking up a pawn
picking up upon
so once again for David the movie you
want to play is castles but I'm worried
about like a knight of five jump that's
like maiden five if you get castle feel
like 94 Bishop H1 hang on a second I
thought there was still Knight of six
Knight H5 but yeah maybe it's much safer
just to keep that monster Bishop along
the Dag
absolutely a very nice diag here and of
course now we can put the queen on G6 in
some cases maybe G5 but that runs into
F4 I have to be careful with this also
Bishop I can't forget about the sneaky
Bishop in the corner
yeah you can't but also that [__] fun
H1 just Dynamite here I think you can
take with either the bishop or the queen
he tells me
it sounds better Bishop's AC4
yeah I mean ikara would call that just a
wooden Shield there in the middle of the
board what a boss
why what's wrong with G6 I think just
the general yeah he drops back with
Bishop F4 is coming uh very shortly
maybe once you play Move Like Rook F1
get out of this diagonal
but also I mean he could just let it
happen
he could I mean you could even long cast
and play F4 give you I'll give you the
Rook if you want in exchange for that
open diagonal I'm just going to mate you
he's up time once again up time up in a
position it feels like here engine likes
white who knew you could get these type
of positions from H3 and A3 on move one
again no ideas like I want to play for
F5 for black but then you just open the
G file for white you expose your king
so besides that I mean five is slow yeah
castles but now you're just expecting
long castles from icaro they're Calm
Before the Storm at some point there
could be a knight of five idea lurking
there could be this F4 which we were
highlighting earlier absolutely feels
like a mate in five in fact maybe not
five but closer to being a mate in
something Castle Queen side I mean you
see the Bishops are swiping the board
here ready to go all we need to do is
get our King safe and open up everything
on this side of the board and this game
is virtually over here pretty nuts
just love watching Hikari making those
faces he's
he's concrete probably calculating
Knight F5 the more that I look at it but
I still feel like you get your king to
safety and then I mean as they say
threat is stronger than the executive
execution very nice yes absolutely
Knight F5 is very strong here but again
you got castling first just seems better
seems better more accurate and then
maybe a knight of five Place F4 you
don't care about nothing I don't care
about nothing now if I take on F4 okay
speaker I think probably here Queens
three F6 oh no there's nothing C3 engine
doesn't like it okay so maybe oh my God
is it a knight H5 is that his concept
it's not H5 it's oh come on give me a
nasty and it takes an intake oh they're
[__] made Seven no there's Bishop seven
mate oh my goodness bro this is gross
[__] look at this this is disgusting
disgusting this is disgusting is this
actually about to happen here so you you
just can't take it you just don't want
that to happen you just don't even think
about but if you don't take I could be I
mean there's fe5 first of all there's
also F5 oof
woof
H3 move one chat this is what I'm saying
I'm about to be playing this all right
checking hey yeah yeah chess comp
checking yeah we're going to checking
yeah take them all back we're gonna have
to check this man
Savage yeah this is I mean can we check
for should we is it too early to make a
bees reference but yeah this is sick
this is sick from here
yeah this is disgusting
oh man and F6 there's Bishop G6 F5 would
be gf5 there's just no way to stop F6
right F6 first off fine go tripping
right don't play F6 secondly look at
this bro this is terrible this is so bad
oh man yeah everything attacked over
here
things have gone horribly wrong
oh yeah yay
tough game tough game bro
okay
and bishop's seven there's Knight G6
there's just really no way to cover
everything
is H3 stuff this is just insane bro you
can play G5 I think well I guess in
Queens Queen C3 oh my God show that idea
are you kidding me it takes Rick takes
blasting open the battery and queen's
three would be an Unstoppable mate on
Jesus
nice fine he might actually play this
thing because Knight G6 I guess that's
David's trick like after Bishop G6 there
would be a knight F3 so not something
you want to allow all right but yeah
he's gonna keep it simple here just
castles it the castle they just got out
of there go Knight D5 or plenty of good
options I'm sure
95 takes uh I mean he's still winning at
least David has survived here like yeah
he definitely come away with this it's
even material I know that car's got two
Bishops and a pretty Mighty hair at that
but still okay still fighting
still fighting this is fighting right
here he's still fighting you know he can
hit but he fighting though he ain't down
yet I mean that doesn't make sense he is
not down yet Bishop takes D5 with check
trying to figure out the kill shot here
Hikaru you could even recapture with the
c Pawn in fact just to put black in a
complete bind tie him down maybe you
would have complete domination over that
position but okay he takes with the
bishop
this is weird enough he is really back
in the game
hang on a second what if I play Rook F1
threatening Rook takes F6 in a rook F1
Knight G6 first ah Knight G6 with the
idea to cut me off 95.
I think you have to go for that but the
moment your knight leak leaves I might
think of H4 a C6
Rook F6 Rook F6 Rook F1 cd5 right you
get a lot of pieces there oh you get a
lot of pieces yeah
so Carl thinks better is it Bishop H1
because still Rook F6
massive threat that needs to be dealt
with 1966
oh he's gonna play with oh E4 C5 pushing
past C5 lock that Bishop up
Bishop temporarily in jail I think you
have to play your knight G6 move though
yeah somehow he's not the way around it
by Allah here B6
camera hold on hold on right Rook F6
Rook F6 Rook F1 D4 Bishop D4
the blend Queen D4
which is why maybe you take on F6 first
in that line
like Rook F6 Rook F6 Rook F1 E4 let's
see
okay F1 D4 and then you play Rook takes
F6 and that is 64 and you're hunting and
I think you've seen before yeah Rook F1
D4 Rook F6 yeah wow and then Bishop D4
and then we're trying to go for May here
Bishop D4 Queen H7 is next so maybe King
E6 um we have Queen H7 why are you
running though Queen H7
I need seven and Bishop C6
there okay
the corner
dang
got him out of there
and that does bring us to our first
break
wow that's the first break here guys
well as you see the mask Score says five
plus one
Five Point uh five plus one portion goes
to Hikaru with three and a half sorry
four and a half yeah four and a half
four and a half to a half four and a
half to a half there Jeffrey this was a
dominating performance as of course the
predictions the smarter chess everything
said that it looks like smarter chess so
far is correct
what do you think Jeffrey
yeah I mean I still just feels like
David
was rattled after that second game and
he should have won that yeah
um since then I mean he's not been able
to recover from this A3 H3 yeah cars
antics
maybe you'll have to look at it on the
break who knows but whatever yeah Scott
we'll see we'll see if he can come back
yeah we'll see if we can come back we'll
take a short break guys and we'll be
back with the three plus one
[Music]
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there he is there is the man he is down
but he is not out that is David caravian
ready to go at it and come back and try
to do an insurmountable comeback of
course down three games see Caro that's
not a lot of games but against Cairo it
is and it's very difficult sometimes to
try to come back as you see the player
card here the straight is creativity
we've been seeing a lot of that with the
h3a3 from Ricardo today qualified here
from the SCC qualifier to get to uh the
main event here so real quick three a
four and a half in fact sorry he's down
four games four and a half to a half
here Jeffrey what's got to happen
yeah it has been rough
um but as you mentioned a very creative
player I've watched this uh SEC
qualifier finals match against men very
closely he escaped several losing
positions there just with his tactical
vision and also his ability to squirm at
a certain spots so we haven't seen that
today just yet obviously Hikaru a whole
nother animal so I hope that he he digs
deep and battles the best he can yeah I
think Hikaru has a punishing type of
style where like you just can't make
many mistakes and then when one mistake
turns into more and then you lose and
it's just very difficult there he carved
with the French defense all right
Jeffrey how you feel about that Chef
Jeff
to draw
true it didn't really I didn't get what
I want but
I don't think I can blame the opening
here we see a very interesting trade
with Bishop G5 followed by H6 Bishop G2
and I don't quite recall the reputation
for this like I thought it was bad for
black if I'm not mistaken but we'll see
what uh what akaro has planned I'm
actually not too familiar with this line
actually
Bishop G5 H6 yeah I actually always take
um after Bishop before I always take on
D5
yeah just to simplify it
first time I've seen this position F3
wow just allowing Queen H4 but Bishop F2
is there whoa
yeah
very very critical
check c33 oh you're collecting a ton of
Pawns that's what I'm saying here right
and I mean like what is it with the
bishop yeah Queen C what is this really
and then King F2 huh and like this is
what we have I still like white I still
like white it's got a head count though
let's get a head count so you got three
pawns yeah so far right I guess you
can't
maybe you can actually take a fourth on
E5 I'm not sure
yeah which one you have Queen yeah yeah
rookie one you've got Queen B2 Queen B6
Jeffrey Jeffrey here oh my goodness he
going for it look at the riskiness here
and go back maybe and you got four pawns
wow yeah this would have been
interesting but Hikaru is not going to
entertain us with that he's gonna
entertain us with a knight on H7 though
what do you make of that oh a knight on
H7 this is pretty gross I'm not gonna
say anything else like that's just the
best way to put it this is a disgusting
knife but you have to put it on like G6
or D7 I mean this is the bad thing about
the French right if you get a bad
position it's bad it's really bad and
this is this doesn't look that good for
a car get honest well that H5 move does
set up uh the knights post on G6 so now
his whole point is you can't ever kick
him with H4 H5 yourself
so yeah I mean I agree with you it does
look
problematic especially after C3 just
keep the Queens followed by Bishop D3 oh
maybe oh I don't like trading there I
thought oh Queens yeah absolutely what
is he doing damn it you know okay wow I
mean I understand he wants to stop the
bleeding here at least he's very safe I
don't think he can ever lose this
position
yeah that's true it's just uh yeah you
would love to see more then trading at
Queen's there and black is totally fine
too as well though usually in these
positions I mean Black's fine we do have
the space on E5 but we can't really use
it that much yet we like to play G4 and
F5 but you can't even do that so
yeah I don't think you're ever getting
F5 in this game A6 and nice to buy a car
restricting the Knight and B3 as well
restricting the Black Knight on A5 so
here as white I'd be looking to try and
get my Bishop into like
more active Square I'm not sure uh
something maybe like Knight F3 here
followed by Bishop okay first Rook G1
and then Bishop B6 get some activity oh
yeah Richie one Bishop B6 very nice
stopping anything on the d8 you have to
develop pretty obvious Bishop D3
Knight to E7 nice maneuvering from
Hikaru here it's a back and forth game
trying to grind and gain some ground
somewhere A4 stopping B5 and F6 very
nice Palm break you control the Palm
brakes you control the gank but we have
a palm break as well on C4 F6 is a very
nice break
aha yeah I'm not sure what to make of
that you do
uh we can the E6 Pawn but at the same
time get a nice Square for your key on
F7 there's no Knight G5 you have to
worry about so definitely a pros and
cons to that absolutely of course I
can't play Knight D4 I would love to
play Knight D4 and like take on F6 and
then try to B6 but even as it takes a
long time Rook D2 may be trying for E2
and eventually doing something on the
e-file
yeah this is going to be a very slow
maneuvering game black has an idea okay
B5 is one I think after ab5 he intends
to capture with the bishop you're ready
exchanging a pair of Bishops
neutralizing the bishop pair so David
most likely shouldn't allow that I would
go A5 probably
A5 also training Bishops makes E6 weak
but can be easily defended yeah A5 is
good right yeah I think you definitely
don't trade Bishop I'm also wondering
about Rook A1
Rook A1 ba4 and maybe just be A4
ba4 takes them where it came on but also
rookie won first but then B4
hard to evaluate all of these and
there's always a rook H6 Rook G6 idea
that I want to point out um
that weakness on G3 that is correct you
see this it's very fresh it's going
right forward yeah that's an annoying
idea oh my goodness so annoying or even
deal with this because the knives are so
solid here defending each other well the
good news for white is after Rook q6
Knight G3 is still not a threat due to
the pin right and Rook G4 you still have
Knight H2 at your disposal however
the minus for white is black is so Rock
Solid everywhere you don't have a single
break now with the opponent B5 no more
C4
and yeah I don't really see what plans
there are so the French is too A lot of
times you get these annoying positions
where it's rock solid try to push for
more and you end up losing but I can't
get five I think he just wants something
like this Bishop's a C5 but there's
always Knight C6 so I don't need to
venture any further yikes shape maybe I
think a car is content with just waiting
he knows that
um if David doesn't overextend he
doesn't really have any um
sort of targets to to go after so he's
just going to wait here okay Rook H6
we're not
gonna Shuffle the other round Bishop B6
long-winded maneuvering game it takes a
while it should be B6
yeah I
don't really I I mean I'm trying to
evaluate if you reconfigure your Knights
like puts the other now G4 but don't see
the benefit so I would honestly just
come back with that night go Knight hf5
here you go so he goes to G4
yeah but not Ricky too at least well
where's he going oh he wants to pawn but
I mean no but you're never I feel like
you're never taking on E5 and giving up
the G5 square right right
unless you're putting pressure on it now
this is probably just
but perhaps we're yeah it would be
better
I mean I still feel like we're at a
standstill both sides right don't have
breaks they don't really have clear
weaknesses either it's just a waiting a
lot of a lot of uh waiting three right
you see uh nothing this is waiting is
waiting here
I'm gonna be two
yeah I trying to see
if you go 97 yeah I mean there's just
King B2 not really not much going on
here at all
here they could we could Shuffle it out
but I think Hikaru always likes to push
for more always here he takes whoa that
is surprising
huge very surprising and after if he's
five he doesn't really care about Knight
G5 I guess I guess yeah I'm very very
intrigued to see what he has with this
97 Knight G5 Rook F1
Bishop D4 what is this move defending
okay
guess he wants King Jade or Rook Cafe
yeah just to try and
play on the f file yeah he's totally
fine he says your car was like yeah I'm
good like so what look at the Knight
controlling the squares
that is a good example he does control
that critical G6 Square so your Bishop
cannot harass me
wow this is nice maybe he gets away with
this oh hold on but I just I see an idea
for white now what if I go B4 okay B4
with the idea with Bishop C5 oh you want
Bishop C5 Okay so
what can I do about this I could just go
Knights C6
uh okay you want to take one before
rookie oh wow engine's like that is not
but now Bishop C5 and Bishop G6 yeah I
was gonna say release the G6 square and
the Rooks like this is crazy you can
barely move
I think he missed that idea though he
played Rook C2 which is a bit slow and
this is giving a car the opportunity to
jump in with the other Knights F5
92.5 very strong Knights these Knights
as he likes to say
it should takes F5
this is this is uh you're gonna give
this up I don't think so
there's a bishop G6 Bishop five Rook F5
is also not in the way you want all
right but there's not yeah
I don't know what to suggest though like
G3 is here yeah all right it's Gotta
play solid yeah what else can we do here
wait isn't there oh my God wait a minute
that's it 90 hold up hold up 95 does he
go rookie do we see anything there I'm
gonna see anything no no no rookie one
rookie19 C6 no this doesn't work for
white yeah there's uh there's no
expression he definitely hung upon there
but there is no expression from us good
calm and collected there
now you can go either 93 or Knight C6
with probably Knight C6 I like a bit
more I see 6 30 94.
oh my goodness
yeah we got a checking checking yeah we
got oh my and now night six this is a
great inclusion A5 huge Target whole
position collapsing now for David you
take on C3 and D4
B4 was nasty ic6 but we saw B4 even
stronger
oh and Rook A5 comes with check good man
and E5 oh man it's piling up
so if I'm no good
job
for Bishop G6 Knight before next
every piece working together here Rook
A2 Knight D3 is is a safety three
Knight F2
and a rezzy
and a rezzy five and a half yo hey we
gotta let's get some Davis in the chat
man uh like he got to get a game you
know what I mean he has to get a game
right it's looking rough can he get a
game Jeffrey
oh man and one before by Hikaru so
slightly I want to say this is like a
principled approach now that at least
he's fighting for
some squares but yeah he's the car is
just gonna keep on rolling with these
these uh offbeat openings yeah I'm
rooting for David I'm rooting for David
to at least crack one of these openings
okay he's tried H3 A3 B4 it doesn't
matter what he's playing he's winning
right now and David needs to strike
somewhere hopefully he's able to strike
in this game I already like Black's
position
well in retrospect though I think the D5
Pawn I mean to place a bit of Devil's
Advocate it's gonna be a permanent
weakness that you have to worry about so
I think again hikaros like this bishop
maybe just go rookie one here not to
blunder anything uh any tactics along
the e-file play very safe very solid D5
sort of london-esque but you actually
liked a nice misplaced like where do you
put your pieces I guess you have to
slowly develop a rookie one definitely
seems I think yeah you start with rookie
won the Knight D2 next
working one 92 Knight F3
yeah and for for black I mean the bishop
and F6
it's not terrible by any means but you
do stare right into this brick wall with
the c3d4 E3 structure so long term I
feel like white oh he wants to five I
was not expecting but I guess we can get
away with it
wow I guess you can yeah rookie won next
and is bullied upon wow oh what whoa D4
all right David says oh my goodness
David come on David I'm all swing back
swing back David I like it that's a
strong move so if CD4 there is Knight D4
which would be huge
everything lots of good ideas here the
Bishops just start shining so
what if you take on C6 for white this is
my question so you mean uh D4 I'll take
on C6 first yeah so we gotta take back
right wait do I have I'm not sure I'm
not sure you might have some inner
messes you have both D3 D3 and DC3
actually yeah they're both moves I
wonder does this work here maybe I think
I take on E8 here E8 gobble as much as I
takes takes and C2 oh and both Rooks are
hitting in the night but how somehow why
is everything yeah yeah I mean don't
forget that white is up a rook and a
knight in the current position yeah this
is nuts right now this has been nice but
it is neither here nor there he's played
F3 another
way to deal with uh see what happens
wait F3 here F3 okay now we're gonna
play D4 nice so wait do we take it now
no he has nice C3 after this is in
Queens yeah this is a crucial moment I
feel like DC is the way to go with your
queen D1 and C2 ideas in the air we see
David with the hair twirl action he
knows that this is his chance to pounce
twirled in the fade he twirled in the
fade guys he had a lot more hair and
then he got a little fade there you see
the lineup crispy he twirling it right
now as he's sitting here trying to
figure out what to do fighting back as
he's fighting this monster in car
Yeah Carl you might have seen something
shaking his head there looking around
looking at the ceiling looking at his uh
orange background I wonder if he sees a
nice continuation here for David
shaking his head he always says that
yeah it's just like oh so poor so bring
up five games bro yeah even if he's
adopting his opponent he could he will
say these kinds of things
I'm right yeah he's just like that you
know he likes to be critical of himself
a lot
all right so what do we do here I'm
looking I'm still liking D takes E3 and
if Knight takes C3 I think I take on E3
so you like DC3 I do okay and queen d8
and we take okay we're okay d8 no I
think with the a I I take it with the a
really okay yeah so that I saw rookie
three and I saw Knight oh we have rookie
three now right rookie three now
whoa sorry to sorry to cut you short he
played Bishop E6 that was not a move I
was considering wow it should be six not
a movie we considered at all in fact we
did not even check this apparently the
engine thinks that this is good because
regardless of how you take I guess
Bishop C4 very nice is his idea and then
he's gonna take on D4 tactically just
like we saw on draken do this to who
again that game I forgot I think you did
commentary on that too but he took on D5
and then three wow I forgot what that
was it was like a check Pawn on A6 long
diagonal Bishop thing this reminds me oh
yeah yeah against Levon yeah yeah that
game yeah yeah he played white he played
white yeah yeah it was very nasty tactic
he found this kind of looks like that
with the same kind of idea
hey Carl's gonna try and exchange some
stuff off relieve some of the pressure
take on d8 probably Rook E1 I guess but
it's very passive for
for white
hmm
yeah very passive I mean the Knight is
still hey I can't move it yet I guess it
is two pawns after all though it is two
Pawn so maybe he just wants to say all
right I'll play F4 next I'll just play
with my bishman G2 Rook on E1 for the
moment
and yeah you show me show me your
commentation oh now he gets out wait why
do you allow Knight A3 I don't like it
he played that boy so quick I mean
obviously you gotta get that night out
Rick C1 now you want to see one I see
two I think it car is out of the woods
he just says I'll give you the pawn it's
whatever you can have it bro take with
the bishop you're getting pinned
trafficking H1 Maybe
but I guess that's David yeah you go
rookie three here I think he doesn't
have any winning chances just go rookie
three take that swap another Rook pair
with Rook D2 call it a drone at least
get yourself to bleeding right stop the
bleeding get get yourself uh back on the
board here hey that looked better on the
scoreboard I'll be fine with that five
and a half one and a half shoot
one one to six like like oh man you're
getting beat but at least you beat him
like no I didn't beat him I got two
draws but still I'm up I'm still on the
board
still on the board stop the bleeding yep
it's gonna be very hard to lose
yeah I know here he's not going to lose
but how how can I'm wondering if they're
gonna play this on a little bit
okay was very Relentless with that and
looks like he is playing on so far he
wants to just play this boy on milk the
clock as well he declined to draw for
let me see um dropstone offered a draw
you are such a beast wow he literally
declined it
well I mean we've already seen the A3 H3
this could be another episode of that
disrespect everybody all on the same
side Jeffrey all the pawns on this
they're the same pawns Jeffrey
no I mean even
uh even my dad could draw this again
that's the truth
oh man chat this is a draw all the way
but all right I mean I understand I
understand the meta from Chicago he
knows that in bullet he's a huge
favorite if he has a any sort of lead
there so just to play few or five minute
games uh make sense from from that
regard yeah stalling the clock too as
well I think it's very mad good match
strategy of course
um is hey hey you know yeah I'm up but I
want to win this all the way no
questions asked at all I'm going to lay
this out as long as we can
and uh I should mention it's also
getting a little bit late there for
David late in the evening maybe he wants
to put him to sleep in the sand game
yeah definitely can go to sleep real
quick here real fast Chad
real fast
here there's nothing here
I was thinking he ain't really thinking
yeah I really thinking he just milking
the clock chat milking a clock
I mean what else what other things can
we discuss you following World Cup I
mean you know what yeah right exactly
Chad right World Cup you know who's your
team what's going on what you have for
breakfast check we can go through your
whole day right now it's gonna we're
gonna be here a while
wow
what's your next tournament Jeffrey
I actually have a long break I'm gonna
be on Christmas vacation pretty soon
going to Cancun Mexico so very excited
about that and yeah just celebrating the
holidays next tournament probably in
February I would say
where is that
uh I think it's it might be this local
tournament in Dallas uh Southwest class
oh Southwest class okay
I'm familiar with that
good luck to you bro yeah thank you I
saw you grinding as well you had a great
event there in Charlotte I saw you
streaming at all the updates I did man
it was great probably actually my
greatest tournament I've ever played I
played Four GMS only lost to one so it
was very nice experience confidence
boost and also just you know going
forward what I need to work on this is
pretty good I gotta tournament January
so wishing the best just keep working
oh man that is awesome and I think I
speak for everybody in the room we all
want to see you play more Super
underrated I think you know that by now
and yeah just get more experience keep
keep on uh moving forward let's keep
going that's all it is and uh we still
here Jeffrey we're still here
we still here the paint has not dried up
just yet wow
we're gonna be here for a while
I do admire that Hikaru really has no
shame like he just wants to do whatever
is best for him and the match doesn't
care about I mean he doesn't have to
worry about us he doesn't have to worry
about the viewers just whatever helps
him win that's what he's gonna do that's
it you see he push the pawn in there
just so he you know the 50 moves thing
like I mean he gonna be out here for a
long time
G4
progress
uh okay all right he trying to fight uh
oh
there's nothing here chat I'm just
trying to be hyped there's literally
nothing here
at all Shuffle
you know we never get his time out there
enjoy this time that we're having
together this meanless time literally we
just
doing nothing Chad
yeah we saw the graph there it's down to
one percent so you're saying there's
still a chance
a mighty one percent one percent but hey
one percent is not a hundred right it's
not at a hundred percent I have a chance
I actually have a chance
all right here we go with the King
Shuffle 40 moves to go try this at home
don't don't do this check I'll try this
out unless you're in a SCC mat
right unless you're gonna SCC mat
yeah we saw Wesley do a little bit of
this but it made a lot more sense I
think uh late in the game just playing
the games all the way out running out
the timer it does feel early though how
much time did he run out like how long
have you been here Jeffrey this is a
long time this is a long time guys
oh my goodness this is such a long game
I mean and I have a feeling this might
not be the last time in the match we'll
see something like this I guess
look at that look at that
hey checking the move counter he wants
to probably run his clock all the way
down before he makes the 50th move
wow
that's so funny
I mean he can he can he can pre-move
like 10 more moves with his King and
just take a nap just go to sleep here
that's right just take a nap you really
could pre-move your king and just like
you know let me go to bathroom I'll be
right back get some food
I'll be right back
wow how many moves left I'm not
following I'm not following either I
don't think anybody's following nobody's
following this right now no everybody's
like when is it going to end just all
right count it count it when are they
done with this game right here this
seems like the moment yeah occur taking
sip
probably
we're at move 50 I I would guess who it
felt like that movie it'll move 50 right
we all move 127 right now Chad
127. I mean the way I think hikaru's
psych part here definitely will if you
don't have a strong you know mental you
could you could have already cracked
here now of course the chess is another
story it's hard to play obviously Cara
but you know the A3 stuff the H3 stuff I
I can't even get a draw when it's a draw
you know what I mean like he's not even
giving me this I have to fight for
everything it's a it's going to be a lot
to face Hikaru whoever faces him
oh yeah I mean he's gonna toy with you
in every regard to the game like
psychologically I feel like he just want
to get in your head there just drive
David crazy oh my God yeah all right
we're back we're back now different
opening every game he's playing
something different oh yeah we saw Kara
Khan we saw a sicilian con we saw a
French and now we get in alakins every
open I think he's just showing that I
can beat him which shows the level of
strength he's playing at right well he's
played in every game he's played
something different every game and he's
been able to win besides this one draw
he just had there obviously but
showing some extremely strong strength
from the four-time SEC champ
and I like this four pawns I think it's
picking up a lot of steam as the main
response to the alkynes you try and take
full control of the center and bolster
it here here you can probably go Castle
tour Bishop V3 I think
both moves are playable yeah I'm a big
fan of these positions for white
actually I mean of course uh alakai or
aliac how does it say eliakin right you
know like you're saying it wrong you
know it's a very uh provocative those
people those guys oh you're saying irony
like 1200 you know but of course there's
no shame to the 1200s but you know yeah
the alkyne is very very different
difficult opening sometimes the face
they do pressure the center a lot but I
think white didn't press blackden
pressure as much as they usually do so I
think he's okay maybe he's gonna play F6
though next right I recall the bishop
normally being on E7 and then they try
and undermine with F6 so Bishop B4 okay
gives the option and David takes it by
cutting off this bishop with the move C5
oh takes takes yeah I think you had to
take on C3 otherwise there was a knight
a480 and your Bishop might have been
stranded nice
so yeah we get this sort of structure
probably F6
yeah I definitely F6 break it up C4 it
might be too much Knight B4 and I see
two ideas gotta worry about that wow I
guess we have to take on F6 huh
well it's still a nice position you know
you control the center you've got that
Bishop pair which everybody loves
all right he's gonna chip the other one
with B6 also makes sense
okay takes episode of the Carroll Khan
esque with the bishop outside the Quan
chain type of scandi with the D5 square
a lot of blend of openings here nice
Bishop on F5 Knight H4
it's coming up to me Bishop B5 would be
an idea to go after the other Bishop
because we should be five now after 97
there is a C4 move which would have
trapped your knight so that's why he's
leaving that square vacant
um preparing to drop back in the case of
C4 I like this though I like this for
David
oh yeah those Bishops are active
these Bishops are very active pieces the
Bishops 97.h4 would already be winning
on the spot uh wait a minute wait a
minute and if you move the queen C4
traps tonight isn't this might be close
okay you have to play F6 but that
weakens your King's side 100 and then
Pawn takes I think you take with the
pawn in fact maybe you have to I mean
you can't let that knight jump into E5
the uncontested and Bishop H6 Rook F7
and there's nothing and then you remove
Knight H4 can come in with with
authority maybe six a mega Target this
is terrible for black this is it is
chance come on David
come on David
breathe David breathe oh resignation all
right he's on the board on the score
column first dub
back to H3 for a car back to Ace three
like this is bread and butter he's 3g4
well until yeah that's a big dub kind of
punishing a car for you know dueling out
that uh obstacle or bishop and game yeah
but now he needs to prove that he can
punish this h3g4 opening this is a big
moment I feel yeah if he can win uh two
in a row he's gonna feel a lot better
you know I think confidence raises you
feel better about playing and then you
know sometimes it even uh shakes up your
car I've seen Carl lose what was that
two in a rough course he has a big lead
anyway he had a big lead but he lost
that was a two Duda actually cgc and he
lost two in a row actually to Duda even
though he beat him like three four-row
before that something like that right
right he could be streaky he can be
streaky right it can happen
so now some sort of grob now we have I
guess the H3
you'll likely lose the tempo because I
expect him to push H4 down the road
but still I mean it's a solid structure
here probably D for D4 keep it
symmetrical
page for now
okay prediction is up to two percent now
guys look at that okay that one win
let's go ahead and steady climbing yeah
every Point that's it don't count me out
never count me out says David two
percent
you know he's going to keep fighting
until he drops and this 96 I like it
he's going to maneuver the Knight around
at E6 maybe jump into F4
oh Bishop B3 here he doubled his chances
that's right BJT doubled his chances one
game that's all it takes double now wait
a second yeah David had the same
reaction as me I'm stunned that occur
exchange those Bishops and now nothing
is controlling that F4 Square I feel
like David can really massage the dark
squares uh in hikaru's Camp especially
after 96 that's a very strong move you
have to maybe go 92
to deal with it
they're also a queen once but the other
night I like it night of it made G6 he
lost this one you know open up the
bishop if 92 maybe bishop G4
um potentially yeah potentially annoying
because you'd also bring a Queen E3 yeah
you'd bring uh all the pieces into the
game
quite annoying actually
so as a car what do you do like H5 you
cut off G6 but then the Knight would
just plant itself on E6 E6 how about a
move like Queen F3 yeah he plays it and
then I can Castle Queen side but maybe I
go 90 exactly because it was nice yeah
now 92 I don't give you the bishop G4
and also put my queen on E3 so some
flexibility here after the queen F3 move
I like it queen of three you also have
Queen G3 reminds me of Sicilian it
reminds me of some type of Sicilian
again you go G4 G5 there's a what is
this which one is that time enough
Sicilian G4 G5 Queen F3 Castle Queen
side you play B3 you're right they're
hand stem yeah that can't stem from
Attack yes yeah very nice very nice
position I think here for white here
aggressive intentions
so now how does David want to set this
up because yeah 96 now probably Knight
G2 to counter this
however those squares D4 and F4 wait a
sec maybe Knight G2 Knight D4 anyway I
was just thinking that takes takes and
the queen B4 and then exactly and that
would force your king to uh King F1 move
yeah so Queen G3 instead
attacking
try and understand this so Knight F4
Knight G2 I guess
is the point
oh yeah Knight of 492. the 96 it goes
with the other night ah stupid
ah you could reinforce yeah he's going
for it 92 96 just put the other one
there just be a nuisance to society
although 96 maybe I go Bishop H3 I'm
gonna get rid of those Knights yeah we
gotta get rid of them you ride this
space three is like yo these nights
gotta go it's too much going on it's
blocking everything I do like this one's
first yeah and actually I guess he can't
keep this h12 open if black were the
castle there would suddenly be H5
with that pawn storm coming forward
there's also the famous maybe G6 than H5
but also of course uh they can play G5
after H or FG I think G5 First bishop D7
hold on Jeffrey you know we got we
always sack first thing later about
those ideas
quite yet black is uh still solid right
yeah it's not there yet but definitely
definitely gotta remember this oh man
that's fine and David wants to wants to
Castle along get his King to save so I
like to move Bishop H3 Force the knights
off the board uh you're not going to be
able to keep that uh that Outpost
Knight H3 Queen E5 is Knight F2 it's not
ready yet definitely some potential lots
of stuff you can do close there but I
guess Knight H3 just go Rook H3 I love
Rook H3 keep an eye on E5
as well
yeah there would be like a knight F4
tactic but you just dropped the Rook
back keep things simple and play a
knight against Bishop sort of position
we also have some F4 in there too we can
play F if you could flick that in yeah I
would love White's chances you got some
you would open up pressure on the f file
lots of different possibilities could
come to fruition but it is David's move
here does he Castle Queen side or if you
Castle point should I take on E6 so yeah
I think you have to go for this like
maybe just Queen C7 though you can see
seven we back up and how do we put
pressure on you nothing yet oh stage
five
or I play an annoying move like Queen E3
to stop your long Castle idea oh not
sure it's quite annoying I mean I can go
Rick F3
I don't know what to do after Rick F3
though
Knight g395 is It's Tricky Tricky this
night's very very tricky black has a
nice it is it is dominated by the pawn
C6 Robert loves to illustrate that kind
of configuration but David
think he's a little bit too long for my
liking I think you just got to go
through guts oh I know four big fella
hey yeah I saw you yeah this was uh is
this possible opening up that Discovery
that's cute I might just take it to be
honest the king is in the center whoa
taking sack of full rookies hey uh
no there's nothing he just blocks he
just blocks him yeah this is too much
especially perhaps too adventurous
the Carl is thinking about something
maybe he's thinking about Rook D7 wait
it's something right you can smell it in
the water bro you literally smell it
it's something Rook takes takes Knight
F4 takes takes yeah
though there's Rook d8 number okay queen
of seven
takes takes takes takes we're hitting F7
Rick f8 Rick check nobody
all right not better of it I guess he
didn't like Rook uh af8 at the end of
the line and black would uh
yeah so yeah
this one are more traditional stuff okay
it's 392 E5
here it comes and I like that F4 idea
which you uh mentioned a while back so
okay first you gotta protect with King
B2
and then I think you're gonna launch
with F4
yeah of course Colleen
nothing King B2
and he's out of there he's out of there
David took the first chance he could get
to get out of town there F4 is very
strong
it's night it doesn't have the greatest
squares wow and I see one with the
reason he's gonna maneuver yeah he's
gonna be out to D3 first
with the reroute
Stills quite solid for both sides I
think David can
I'm looking at an F5 Pawn break I don't
know if
that's good but
you ideas you can also be really solid
here with bishv6 and F6
that's how that's probably it would I'd
like to sprout a lot it is very solid
but should be six Knight D3 F6 take take
Queen G7 Rook f8s
I don't know I mean I feel like I'm if
it's loose it feels a little loose F6
he's going for it yeah maybe there's
also H5 here H5 with the idea of H6 to
try and Shadow but he's gonna go for
your right there it is yeah this is
loose but I mean queen H7 Pawn 87's
hanging my guy do you have an attack
maybe maybe he wants F5
F5
yeah but I don't buy it I mean there's
Queen G6 there ah correct right division
yeah yeah
it feels like a bluff I mean queen H7
the C5 C4 you think that could be
dangerous
this was what I was looking at that is
kind of dangerous it's kind of but worst
case no but I've got Queen E7 there with
a double attack oh Queenie seven yeah GG
beautiful beautiful fine yeah so we
don't have to worry about this at all so
if that's the case well now it's there
yeah he's gonna keep the queen but it
looks like a clean Pawn to me like that
H spawn is fast up the board H5 H6 H7 95
95 oh great Spot 95. Great spot
there it is he spots and a car is 86 and
Rick do you want
tactics
very nice
an immediate Counter-Strike David just
got his first win akara says Ah just
gonna play H3 again keep things under
control and it's gonna be a dub for it
Dub City Dub City another dub free Carl
you could go no couldn't just have a
hangs wow I guess I gotta move it I
think that's a good move I don't have to
oh there is still C4 to watch out for
all right let me not
uh dig David's grave up just yet what if
I
hmm no 93 still C4 that's a good move
it's a good move that's what I'm trying
I don't have to move the Knight maybe I
go H5 you don't yeah but h5c4
that's my threat
uh h5c for you right okay now you're
free to cover the D4 Square
David's got no time though I mean he can
fight on as much okay it's B6 there is
no Bishop G4 C5 hanging
hmm
all right Mr G4 Queen E3 drops back yeah
just keeping things under control is
Hikaru coupons for the good should be
enough you'll start pushing I think
maybe should we do it now or do you go
Queen F5 and F3
I would just yeah I would just push that
just push just push it right just pass
pause must be pushed we heard it from
the best push it again are we missing
something take take take how do you say
I think you just push yeah that's it
okay
you want the fans more than enough
the fancy rounds the fancy round any
purpose if you hang on if you promote
there is Queen you want Queen D4
so he's trying to sidestep it first uh
Queen A4 check Queen A4 check here
controlling that square beautiful
and that does wrap up the segment as
well the match clock just expired a
short moment ago as well oh wow
yep
um looks looks good for your car once
again seven two man that man a clean
enough shop chat as you see the
scorecard says seven to two so wait that
rings the bell hang on a sec that rings
the bell maybe you gotta give a shout
out
hate to do this but tip of the cap to
smarter chest who predicted this exactly
very impressive yeah wow wow actually
smarter shows did predict that honest
crazy seven two yep and then uh the
three one is the same and then we see
further one one is going to be A2
therefore a score of 22 to 6. I think
paravian's one percentage went up a
little bit
it did yeah for a slight moment to two
percent might be back down to one we'll
see in any case but now players are on
break I think we'll also take this
chance for ourselves we'll see you all
on the other side
uh excuse me oh yeah yeah yeah we gotta
let everybody know about uh of course
the speed chess championship guys so if
you're loving our coverage of the 2022
speed test Championship you're not going
to want to miss the feet they will wrap
it in place Championship one of the most
highly coveted titles in over the board
chess some of the world's best speed
chess players will go head to head for
the championship watch this space for
updates are we as we expect uh fide to
announce more details very soon the
event begins Monday December 26th and
you can catch all the action here at
twitch.tv chess guy so of course we're
gonna take a short break ourselves and
we'll be right back with three plus one
foreign
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby
the electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
the Championships gmgx here with my good
friend Kenny
when we left off Hikaru just restored
that five-point Advantage
um
then Spruce failing so far though hasn't
it James
yeah smooth sailing of course is always
usually a Hikaru show it depends on who
he's playing obviously but most times
it's a Hikaru show so it really is about
David trying to bounce back here which
we do believe in him he was able to
strike back and crush his alakai in fact
aliac in there that he played and that
didn't work out so
and uh yeah so I think David just got
some some work to do to be honest we all
know that he does for sure and we've got
some Blitz insights here from chess.com
we see oh my God 30 almost 30 000 games
of Carl he's a he's been a reg since the
OG days
um average accuracy pretty nip and Tuck
for both players that 87 percent from
David quite impressive what else do you
make of this card
very very uh strong obviously at
accuracy he's just as accurate one
percent less but the games is where
Hikaru has 21
000 more games than I mean that's just
insane you know the experience level
there is is quite a quite a huge gap oh
yeah there's a reason he's been abort
and Blitz Juggernaut for years
and I saw the nine percent losses by
Flack he never really Flags in positions
where he's not losing though I think
those that eight percent of those stats
were probably positions where he was
just losing and he let the clock run out
so in the time scrambles yeah he's just
he's never letting his flag fall
it's nevertheless of course one of the
fastest to do it here and of course
second only to
um to to Magnus here in the blitz
ratings and number one in bullet we have
a Scandinavian oh I think he's gonna try
every okay he really respect bro I mean
you know what look I don't know if you
would call it disrespect though it's
just it's really fun seeing all that
variety he's mainly an E4 E5 player and
that's like literally the one opening he
has an essayed yet
that's fun man at this point we're just
gonna have to take it to chess box and
there is a big event coming up of course
we're at so of course uh yes certain
point man for the disrespect H3 A3
Scandinavian I'm gonna play anything and
everything in the book on you says
Hikaru and he's Winnie he's definitely
winning with us he'll see was he able to
pull anything out with the scandi I know
Wesley has some very nasty files on the
Scandinavian so I'm curious to see what
David thinks over here yeah indeed
Wesley's E4 chess book course of course
covered all the bases now this queen d8
uh did allow a doubling of Pawns here at
Knight D5 opening up the discovery and
after the trade I feel like David can be
you can claim a slight edge here due to
the pawn structure absolutely just a
slight edge here you do see this a lot
in the French type setups but usually
they'll go A6 B5 and the bishop is
usually this way with the bishop on E7
so this reminds me of that but Bishop's
outside the pawn chain 94 this sort of
looks like which line is that is that
the two knights Carol
yes yes you could get this exact same
little setup here and uh in general
Knight takes G6 would benefit Lex Pawn
structure he would then follow that up
with F5 later on uh restoring the little
Diamond Pawn structure so you sort of
want to just leave that Bishop G6 right
now it is a tall Pawn so no need to oh
yeah I'm not even gonna take it why
don't we just I guess if Knight F3 maybe
bishop H5 though uh that one you don't
want to allow so maybe maybe I could oh
but here Bishop B7 I feel like
wait I'm not sure why I didn't go Bishop
there but any case still really
reasonable play from both sides
so annoying
ah he goes Knight F6 so yeah he is
probably gonna play Bishop H5 now oh
okay now we got a block right are we
just looking crazy here
yeah but that pin along the diagonal is
quite annoying is it perfect moment to
strike with uh with C5 or does that a
bit too much
oh okay and we have a no here Hikaru has
been looking up games of Herman clemis
on the brakes and laughing wow so that
Clements opening H3
is uh called the Clemens I think it's
a32 I'm not sure but I know the Clemens
one is H3 and we just got where the
Hikaru was actually looking up theory in
that so you know what I think that's
what I'm gonna spend the rest of my day
doing in fact still oh yeah I've got it
yeah I just want to be serious right now
you know I get he looked up some Theory
so I'm gonna go do that too as well chat
I recommend you do the same and let's
all get together tonight maybe on my
stream and let's talk about this Theory
we find H3 is the Clemens open Clemens
c-l-e-m-e-n-z I think but let's uh let's
look this up let's talk about this yeah
I see what this is Chad
yeah there I was gonna say like some
players or most players will look at the
most topical lines run it with the
engine figure out you know all the ins
and outs of the latest Theory other
players such as the car are going to
look at one H3 and laugh so I mean each
of them
yeah one ace3 and laugh but who's
actually laughing because it worked it
actually worked I mean her car was the
one laughing evidently laughing all the
way with these uh more Innovative
openings
bro Burrell this is crazy so hang on I'm
trying to calculate
can I play a move like oh no Queen E4
check you can take it take on d8 and X
exit out of the pin so he's gonna play
94 instead very logical
and 94.
I like I'm not even gonna lie I like I
like it Carl's position I'm not a scandi
fan myself
but I am a fan
of his position oh for sure he's dialing
up uh huge pressure everywhere
specifically on that diagonal plus the D
file if you were to take on d8 here rook
d8 and play a move like this year too I
think there would already be like some
potential fireworks uh regarding like a
knight F2 potentially
so yeah lots of things for David to
worry about
didn't like this at all what is this is
there something we're missing take take
there's no checks no good checks
interesting I don't see anything that B5
is nice although David might be counting
on like a 95 at some point but but B5 is
very strong because you'd Force the
queen back to me too
B5 yeah and queen E2 but didn't have a
weakness and how do I follow you have a
weakness yeah I mean you've got my
knight F2 idea at your disposal I don't
know if that's the best
but at the very least you are going to
win material of some sort isn't there
just oh no you have B5 so he goes for it
um
certainly the right first step now I'm
calculating Knight F2 Rook F2 Bishop F2
Queen F2 you take on F3 that should be
good though that should be good yeah it
goes for it
he goes for it I'm just getting this
change out of it
yeah Wow Let's Get The Exchange what
about Rook T8 to move tonight oh I can't
listen this is
seriously the queen and then the Rook
bro he just lost a lot of material what
a move
yikes
that's a tough move bro that's it yeah
you can't do anything about this trying
to come up with something
it's hair twirling like crazy but I'm
not sure that's gonna help him Twirl in
the face with this twirl on the face
trying to make some work oh E3 is clever
oh 24 check oh all right hit the button
hit the button the start of the new one
I think regardless of his position he's
gonna shake his head all right oh man up
a queen oh this is terrible it's
terrible I'm not up two queens bro
brought to you
yeah not much for David if he takes on
B5 there's just Bishop F3
okay
now here's the question will we see yet
another Clemens
was a car uh making some updates there
improving the the H3 Theory hey look I
would love to see it um we learn it
today H3 come on come on come on oh all
right uh this is too traditional though
this is this is too sound I feel
right it's too sound for what when now
are you bored with something that's
obviously strange but he has a very very
good record with the Larson system
usually starts with Knight F3
right Knight F3 first maybe more
principled but still very interesting I
think he can play a few different things
Knight F3 again is a move whoa E4 is not
what I was going to suggest though yeah
that's usually not a move but I mean hey
you know he's gonna make it work he went
to play E4 make his different G3 just
pushing everything H4 H5
yeah these are some funny moves to bang
out
probably Knight F3 or H5 he's gonna
follow it up five for the center
I think neither fate though you go
Knight of Fate put this Knight on E6
okay yeah first gotta go D6 ah maybe
white throws in a D4 before uh
I mean before black puts it puts a stop
to that beautiful move beautiful it has
to open up or not hold up no no no no no
no no D4 you Chloe uh Ed foreign
I mean still still you you have
permanent control of D4 Square which is
what's important
Bishop to H3 A6
B5 probably
yeah maybe
an H4 maybe no but he just puts them out
on D4 yeah
it's a good move you create lift uh on
A7 for your Bishop no more Knight A4
ideas
and for a card it's difficult how do you
how do you really finish development
he's good try your knight H4 idea yeah
and that is four for Knight F5 I guess
but like D4 is just yeah it's
so what I thought he would go with this
line it seemed a little better to at
least have the bishop to hell too but
now maybe he wants to do it he wants to
keep uh some like Knight F4 potential
ideas in mind making use of uh like uh
hanging out on H4 if white were to cast
but right in this case uh maybe just
take on E2 here keep it simple Play
Bishop D4
is Queen of six
we trade everything there's a bad Pawn
on D4 though and I get F4 in no but
thanks yeah yeah maybe just take it oh
he's gonna 94 I probably recapture with
a piece Bishop first right and then take
with the Knight yeah yeah
something like that
so I'm looking at Bishop takes E6 but
could be a little much but I just want
to give you that that uh double those
Double D puns you were mentioning
this is definitely not white wanted out
of the ocean oh wait a second okay I
almost
what you got I thought there was like a
knight C2 sort of Discovery because
let's not forget about the F2 Pawn
Scholars made ideas
sorry King D1 is nothing there but close
there it is yeah yeah that's that's what
he's aiming at like that's so funny
right Knight B3 doesn't work is the same
idea Queen can get out
E6
um
yeah no discovers here night City or
Knight B3 there's a knight of three
eventually there is no three three but I
think I take it and then Queen F3 Maybe
do I have time to take no I don't have
time to take one F7 wait you might be on
to something
Rook F1 and then Bishop Bishop E6 trying
to play Bishop A3 but he might have had
Knight C3 there oh yeah
it's just a lot it's a lot right
calculation wise F4 oh very nice
love it trying to open up shop it's a
wild game
I mean I don't know what's going on here
I guess Rook F1 is on Tap maybe a knight
of three or Knight of five
so for David he might have to figure
some things out concretely
oh yeah he's getting out the way I like
it and then put a rook on the file with
a smile here Rook F1
yeah I'll do like the the looks of Rook
F1
maybe Black's got to go Knight D4 at
some point just to uh relieve that
pressure line diagonal oh definitely
Five Spices
who castling where what are we gonna do
here right what what is this okay Rick
F1 you you ain't casting me either I'm
not casting you're not either bro here
we go Rick F1 strong move threatening
takes on E5
and the only way you have to go here
yeah the only way to deal with this I
think is Knight D4 because if you move
the queen you drop off that pawn on E5
what is this just don't threaten
anything oh it's H5 I guess holy cow
this looks chaotic exactly like you
can't take this so we take here he says
lots of Pawns hanging there's a rook of
five potentially in here Rook at five
yeah like a D5 or like a five and then I
take 35 yeah yikes let me talk about a
position what is actually going on
later in no time oh yeah I just noticed
that both players getting low on the
clock in a razor-sharp position so this
could go either way
absolutely
maybe you go Queen H5 and like if Rook
F5 you just play Queen G4
D4 there's Bishop B for check that's my
concept
oh oh the D4 yeah Bishop before check
yikes
it's getting nasty in there checks
everywhere it made it actually
tons of tactics in there like G3 could
also be hanging some lines the open B
file could be a factor castles he just
Castle the B4 Oh I thought I could stack
hold on but okay anyways it goes for
this oh is there a knight takes D4
Knight D4 Queen
oh my God everything was hanging he
missed it hey Carlos saws until you see
shake his head there shaking his head
and disgust but I think this is still
favorable for black like if you go D5 I
play Knight D4 anyway and that King has
nowhere to run nowhere to hide on either
one yeah King in the middle of the
street here right now in the middle of
the street about to get hit by something
as uh David though just gotta keep
moving you see six keep moving
so many weeks we'll just chill bro you
wanna trade you might have to you might
have to force a queen trade somehow some
way
one okay now yeah rookie keep [__]
wrong attention yeah take on e4 or H5
25 Knight of three ah there could be a
dangerous pin here it's a c8c3 I still
like Knight F3 yeah Knight F3 would have
been definitely there yeah very tricky
mode five seconds to two seconds occur
living on the increment
rookie one pressure F5 oh he's losing
completely what is the move I have no
idea but yes I thought it was Knight d32
as well it's probably still there
I had a four two seconds
wow one second there
oh my goodness both besides just
blitzing out hoping not to blender
they're like oh 96 this is so oh yeah
he's hanging something's well
something's going on it's winning oh
Queen there's a fork there's a fork on
E6
GG is F5 hating
oh man they have no time to even look
they have guys no no time you literally
don't have any time no time to process
it's just moves now here black is not at
risk though goodness once the Queens
came off we should be able to win this
yeah whoa David Michael
um
those nights are so bad against the a
pawn A2 here
huge Swindle huge Swindle I mean both
sides with no resignation he resigns
oh come on
I can do it on both sides of the board
did you think I couldn't right wow E4 so
now now we know what a car was looking
at during the break
what is this e485 even called
oh man this one's called the wear
defense
w-a-r-e
oh man I mean it looks so ugly you're
giving up this E5 Square permanently
it doesn't what does it do like A5
it's so strange
is that is but okay
that might be more than more than simply
disrespect like I've never seen anybody
play that against me in my entire life
and on the second move right or first
move first move with black with the
black pieces
well how what is the best way for David
do you stick a knight on B5 or do you
stick the bishop
well I remember Joe Bible you know I
like Jar Jar Binks London right so we go
on Knight B5 we're gonna put the Knight
here because that's where it usually
goes in the Joe Bava or Jar Jar Binks
London as we like to call it Knight to
b5c3a4 I could just push everything
that's what it looks like but it is not
that 95. yeah
and this is wow
yeah I mean age four is a big threat
yeah
oh you take and play Bishop D3
Jacob [__] D3 is gonna hold on with
King F7 and they also E5 now it's just
kind of weird how is he even playing
this how is this even playable I mean if
he gets away with this one I won't even
know we can see
and then castles okay cool cool and then
Queen F3 next I'm definitely feeling
this for white well it's suddenly solid
though like you put your other Pawn on
E6 oh you're right these six that's very
annoying it's very annoying actually do
I have anything
can I play Bishop G2
well you can I might go I might just go
E6 anyway though here right I don't even
think maybe F4
try and blast open
the files he does it yeah he does it the
king is just looking crazy looks like a
delayed bomb cloud or something
yeah yeah yeah definitely not not that
good this was definitely looks like some
type of Joe Baba London for sure with
the night early on C3 Bishop comes out
these positions get very wacky Bishop G2
Rook F1 G5 H5 H6 is a very very deadly
attack for white a car making use of
that A5 push it one more Square to A4
saying please take me and then he's
gonna jump in with Queen A5 the night
before all right and just uh who's
attacking new then right
wow and I wouldn't allow A3 here as
David so I think you have to play A3
yourself which is quite annoying isn't
it and then maybe mb5 might be too much
but you might have to take this because
you can't allow B4 so you're kind of
like diverted into this I mean then
there's maybe a rook B8 there's some
strange counter play B5 might be too
much
might be there could also be a knight A5
Knight C4 maneuver that
95 for Knight C4 so Bishop G2 Knight C4
oh yikes who's attacking who really this
looks like there's some Carol Collins
wow exchange Carol Kong I think you're
familiar with that Jeffrey Saints
Carroll Khan King on F7 uh actually uh
um Dean Lauren and a Magnus had a game
with this H4 came with the F7 stuff like
this very very uh topical thing in the
Carroll Khan exchange variation
yeah yeah I mean Hikaru he played all of
the the same moves as an exchange
caracon except he threw in the A5 A4 A5
Queen A5 looking and bringing everything
it looks like a Cecilia now Bishop A3 or
1983 something A3 huge on the way and
white still hasn't started his attack
which is very concerning for me
absolutely and a beef or maybe not ready
yet Knight A3 not ready yet wow what a
move I like this move a lot well why did
you discount B5 so like B5 B4 how slow
is that it just feels very slow but
you're right if B5 what do I do is y I
guess G5 first B4 I take take Bishop G5
F5 yes
still okay car wants to
take use of this open semi-open B file
still Queen b16a1 does he have a sack
uh I don't know first thing I see it but
he goes for this he goes for it how will
it possibly work wait a second B it's
nothing left
oh what is the threat there's no threat
that's right oh maybe it's a thread if I
just Rook up to C8 well Bishop D3 might
hang the D Pawn there it is he went for
it wow
oh my God yeah Queen D4 there's can be
one which David saw and he would have
Bishop G6 there was a discovery but this
is an insane fine
one of them move Bishop D3 He just he
Pro I think that was a practical thing
Hikaru did there oh it was very
practical I mean Bishop D3 was very easy
move to make very easy move Bishop D3 He
plays and it immediately loses right oh
just a nasty trap and here we go on the
other side just flipped the board and
play A4 wow wow A4
yeah you see that was a very practical
trap he set there I think Bishop D3 was
just such an easy move to play and then
Queen B3 ends it on the spot yeah I must
start to lose that game it is getting
really rough psychologically when hikara
can literally play any first move and
get away with it yeah exactly it really
kind of like oh come on right like you
should like on the stop studying the
openings at this point is that what it
is like we we I'm just not even gonna
study anymore so that is a good thing
for you Chad as well do more calculation
training than your openings castles
Castle but now D5 this is very good for
David
very good
we just take and play D4
uh okay let me take E5 Queen D4
ah Knight c493 akara might unwind this
yet again like if he gets a 92 and then
starts pushing the D Pawn you might be
fine
there it is
um
these nice bro come on
how many times have you moved these
looks like super bizarre play but it
makes sense like he's preparing not only
is he attacking the bishop but he's
going to prepare an eventual well I
guess in the current position H3 and
then maybe later C3 and finally push
that d-pawn I mean I'm a big fan of how
practical he's making things he's
playing games of Chess no Theory this is
just chess and this is very good to see
wait a second high level how did he
Blitz that move out
c39 F4 but right for the bishop on B4
geez that's that's super superhuman
stuff very fast very fast yeah of course
we always say he is half a human E4 and
now D4 oh God he's got a good version
once again now Passat and Knight takes
maybe we don't even take first is there
a move in between 95 first oh there
might even be 95. I love that idea
it takes there's no need he says there's
no need to be fancy oh here he's also
got [__] before I just realized I mean
like look at this you get A4 move one
and just if you would tell me you're
getting this position every time where
we're playing this every every game
we'll play something like this right
I guess it's still not
so terrible for blackmail Bishop before
you go Queen C8
control
I think a car might be considering
bringing the Knight back to F4 and he
does he does as he says it takes takes
56 G3 perfect it's got a clean Bishop
pair here no black has no weaknesses
though now I'm a fan no weaknesses very
solid I am a fan of the bishop here I
also do like the black has no weaknesses
at all
and 95 looking for something on the
king's side I don't know do you keep the
bishop on the Diagon or do you play it
safe for Bishop too let's go back to E2
play Queen C2 right and just try to
grind it I am up I have the bishop pair
which I am a big fan of using so I would
definitely grind this out Queen C2
develop the last piece but they'll work
on D1
see what happens yep you could play this
as slow as you want
um all right rookie eight
H3 just covering G4 yeah preparing Queen
C2 but yeah he's softened up that G3
Pawn oh big fella okay maybe not second
immediately
he moves out the way Knight G2
yeah Bishop G3 not working quite yet you
need a little bit more Firepower do you
try and add fuel with uh Rook 88 or 94
it goes Knight D5
it was like D5 Bishop B2 hikaros on the
back foot Queen G3 is a threat he stops
IT King H2 Rook d8 who just bringing the
pieces David I like you David yeah you
said it thank you certainly on the back
foot all of a sudden lots of pressure on
the Central files F2 hanging
additionally what how do you actually uh
resolve this yeah Bishop H5 this is your
move you know I always have some trouble
here look at the pieces David good job
everything in the middle that's how
that's Picture Perfect chess got night
four coming in
let's go David swing back he's like I'm
not going down like that he's swinging
back instance A4 here I think David has
an excellent position but he's looking
to convert pieces on better squares it's
Knight C4 yeah that's right yes there's
like a bishop G5 or the bishop move
somewhere some G5 yeah
and you really want to step on the gas
because if white gets any time to play
moves like Rook 81 or Rook 81 they would
be close to consolidating so it's a
vital vital moment
Queen B6 Bishop F2 idea
whoa Bishop G5 pending
defending by attacking
so strange
but yeah
you can't play M6 down that's kind of
crazy can I take maybe just simply take
put a rook to the middle
whoa whoa develops it undevelops the
bishop disconnecting your own Rooks that
is some that is an elite level move I
feel that is that's that's next level
that's next level it's undeveloped a
piece
but he wants to maintain that Bishop
pair he's saying that black has no real
Invasion squares
and slowly he's going to try and
push uh push black back
heels back to B3
he's gonna try for F5 and maybe take try
to open up the files juicy you could
also play very conservatively with Queen
F2 just force an end game
we have two plate forcing and end game
and Bishop B7 he wanted to trade him
right and then play F5 get the bishop
out G5 oh I love that yeah you would oh
but you've got to be careful there is a
rookie rookie too
interesting
I think takes Bishop yeah I guess Bishop
Fates still both sides maintaining the
tension here
wow
now how about a knight G4 I want to
throw another little wrench here a Twist
F5
oh my goodness so 93 is on pre but the
car is saying that says
everything
[Music]
jet
how to even stop this wait a second
though okay I understand he only has
three seconds yeah King congratulations
oh my goodness you losing big fella did
Hitler that yeah I saw him maybe he had
another
alternative but yeah he forgot queen of
six there's just Bishop G7 there's a G5
check is he mated no checks oh he man
look at the defense David that's a rezzy
you probably get out of here right well
it's not a resident yeah he's got only
two seconds 97 though brilliant defense
correct the defense really was Unreal
wow
there's nothing there's nothing
I'm down
okay of course still trying Rook of five
nice move pin the bishop
the magician at work he's just down a
piece all right he's gonna eliminate
that pawn
once he adds more time I think we can
say for certain but the car is still
probing
you're trying to run the clock trying to
run a clock two seconds here living off
the increment
daily with the defense
three
Mr G5 attacking on B6 check and check
okay
Bishop A6
okay business G5 at some point you just
want to wait oh wow this one ah man what
I guess not I guess not the cleanest
technique but I think he's still got it
take on B2
hang up wait wait gotta move forward one
second oh no but now he's allowed this
no no no this is this has gone out of
control check and push
oh man it's a pawn
repeat is a draw King C4 also
what a magician here I mean this is
crazy even when you went in right I mean
okay you did win a game
oh and now he's gonna have to hold down
man what's wrong get out of here man get
this man out of here bro
I'll be tilted I would be tilted 100
about to knock everything off the table
in front of me but it's so hard to I
mean even when you have the upper hand
against the card you still have to drag
him down and with one second on your
face for so many moves hard to keep up
or just hard
oh man I mean this is tough he might uh
that means hard to lose this but I mean
you do have to like he's got it yeah but
okay wait a second the car is probably
gonna at least take us to
our break here
wait oh goodness there was check yeah
yeah here's the check there's a check
yeah I thought I'd do it a check the
check saved us look at this Chad this is
the scariest place to be on earth right
now is what they're doing
not this time okay the card says not
this time not this time yeah
we can breathe
I've seen a lot of uh in title Tuesday a
lot of King Rick versus King Rook
actually are they're supposed to be
draws but they're wins like how is that
even possible yeah yeah I know how
ambitious players can be in that room
versus King Rook Lucy
yeah we are at this will be the last
game for sure and icaro has Uncorked his
seventh or eighth different opening here
against 24 with B6
yep he's going through every opening
there is Chad he's literally playing
everything and anything and he's up six
games
now for David I probably just playing
with like Knight C2 here
you wanna
stabilize the center with C3 maybe also
Knight G3 some ideas of uh bringing the
pieces over on the king side big fan of
that absolutely 95 okay getting rid of
the defender one of the Defenders of the
king side big fan of your idea though
Knight C2 Knight G3 with the Knight over
there he takes H5 yeah here I thought I
could just take a knight D7
uh just be careful though you don't want
to play Knight F6 that would hang your
Bishop in a funny way with Queen B5
check boom
trying to provoke it probably Bishop
E7
it doesn't allow Knight G5 though you
might have to deal those might just
snatch it there
um you actually snatch it and play
Knight F6 believe it or not I think it's
kind of annoying and you really I feel
like no there's still the queen B5 check
right we'd be fine but they're the
bishops come on after uh you mean Bishop
E7 Knight G5 uh take this oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry yeah yeah this one yeah yeah
you could play that but
I'm not sure hikar wants to part ways
with his Bishop just yet
can he play okay obviously castles has
to be too much like there's another
96.95 Discovery oh man it's almost like
Queen H7 almost works but oh yeah it
does not yeah it does not but like the
uh oh my goodness oh man he lost his
mind what night okay F6 that must be
that must be you gotta be kidding me
you're gonna survive this wow
96 Knight F6 it simplifies like you do
win the light squared Bishop but still
tilting I'll be tilted like you gotta be
kidding me
like yeah the fact is it's not losing on
the spot right Bishop G5 if F6 don't
like to snatch it it literally just
snatched upon right oh yeah seven that's
beautiful Bishop H7 and it's lethal this
is G5 so Bishop B7 Knight F6 anyway
there is Knight F6 yeah that would force
no but Knight F6 and Jesus and G6 that's
gross and he loses jeez that's what
maybe not Bishop B7 still Bishop seven
but a car would be like uh gone with it
before
right
that's crazy that's so tilting bro when
you're like man this is such a nice
position right can I play crazy I still
like my old idea I can't do anything of
night uh Knight D6
yeah we just go with it right and then
it might have said well H4 that's
probably not enough my guy
sorry not enough
now the question is can a car get away
with H6 that's the movie you want to
play but there might be a huge six there
don't even think about it right just do
it you know I'm down in the match
whatever oh yeah yeah he would sack
there uh without this all right right
meanwhile for a car it's not that easy
to find another move like G6 is supposed
to play F5 but F5 is very five takes a
night yeah it was an H6 oh but then 96.
wait no I have Queen on E7 yeah so F5
right oh he does go he plays it as
Bishop takes Queen takes Knight G5 H6
then kick the Knight yeah I guess you
can you can't play like that
yeah because once you kick the Knight
maybe the queen on H5 could find itself
in trouble
yeah
it was nasty F5 no just kick him back
well yeah yeah the bishop is blunted but
E6
huge weakness here you can pile up the
pressure with like Queen E2 Bishop C4
and rookie one oh yeah you're right I'm
about to do that right now right we need
two I mean H6 is scary I'm a queen
trying to try bro
yeah I don't think about that
it'll test the waters we already now six
games bro just let's clean YouTube yeah
didn't you you do allow him to take and
hit mate with Tempo yeah that might be
it okay that might have been what he
didn't like
right check
yeah it is so productive but this is so
productive apparently still there's no
following people going all right check
wow what yeah that would be I would be
slightly tilted I'm not gonna lie I
would be really tilted like you're
getting good positions
oh another five and black could be the
one on the attack like you have Knight
G4 ideas
oh yeah 94 is really strong Queen oh
that's a good move oh Queen E7 rookie
one right that was a nice move nice uh
in between
although what's going on wait rookie won
maybe five yeah Queen side rookie five
maybe in Rook D7 oh [__] oh man oh Joe
where's this [__] that's gonna hurt
that's gonna hurt that's on that's on
tap right now like oh but there's
another there's a counter shot here with
Rook d8 if you take it there's Knight of
three but oh Ricky the engine didn't
like that what's something I didn't I
didn't shoot it all right let's go back
and move I want to see what that was oh
rookie says it was rookie five seven
this would be five
CC I just couldn't find a follow it was
Rick D7 here wow guy takes everywhere C6
gotta move the bishop but Bishop
oh yeah this is finally out of control
again and David just got to make a
decision
okay now
there's a mate threat
Rook F1 Bishop Bishop A6 yeah and he can
hit the button he can hit the button
slamming the Mouse real hard
tough Queen E3 first E3 and Bishop F1
yeah it's all it's all lights out yeah
it takes in a Queenie one anything works
really
that is I mean you know so close there
if David finds that tactic picks up a
big win but
um
it's not there not quite there stop
snatch it and snatch and grab
oh man
plan on as he should I guess
Bishop A2 reroute it again
yeah it's still fighting God admire the
fighting Spirit absolutely
oh okay how to do it how to do it how to
do it
and I believe that does take us to the
halftime of the three minute segment wow
yeah you can see David it's just uh
hands on his head there tough it's a
really tough match here but of course if
we take a look here guys at the match
score right now it's actually two and a
half one and a half he's only down the
game here so far in the in the three one
if we look at it from just match by
match you know or time control by time
control definitely got hurt in a 5-1 but
we're doing okay right now in a 3-1 so
we are going to take a short break
though come back with the rest of it
guys so don't go anywhere
is uh is anybody in snoops Camp playing
chess is that happening or not I haven't
seen it there's some smart people in the
camp so I wouldn't be surprised if
people
our reverse at it very uh a lot of
college educated people you know I
unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp what you talking about man I
don't play chess
I mean you know how to play I listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
everyone to the final match of the SEC
one more ticket up for grabs here we do
see Hikaru with his beloved orange
background got the lit up uh lighted up
pineapple as well that looks nice how do
you like the setup there James you know
it's a traditional it's a classic setup
you've been there a long time so you got
to flex in the YouTube plaques up there
and flexing on his car too as well
Jeffrey
oh yeah I love the whole thing there
okay I wish we could get a bit more of a
look at it but here we see a car was uh
player card
yeah
I love the insights with strength
accurate and fast that would be accurate
pretty decent way to describe his play
and look at that he's the best SCC
finish he's the reigning Champion since
2018 and you know right now looks like
Magnus on the other side of the bracket
is like yeah big fella you might be the
best until Magnuson came around it's
gonna be a heavy metal matchup if we
they make it that far obviously both of
them are favorites to do so but of
course that's going to be a heavy hitter
match up here but we still got this
match to do and David has a long one to
come back from
oh yeah I mean Madison Crow it still is
a long ways to go but I mean I would
just salivate at the potential for that
yeah it's definitely tough B4 the car
with these just like he doesn't care he
literally doesn't care no he literally
doesn't
literally doesn't care I mean you can
just you can tell so they're gonna
repeat this line we've seen before I
think it was takes in D4 Knight C6 now
David had a good position there okay
with the first deviation he developed
his Knight on E2 last time around now in
F3 perhaps more solid
yeah absolutely it's not more solid here
defending D4 as well casting natural
development is usually best of course
obviously you have your ideas with
developing in different ways but natural
development Knight F3 Knight D2 again
natural development here and just
playing a position even though um of
course black have the bishop pair but
having a weak Pawn on D5
yeah and I'm trying to figure out how do
you regroup because okay can we be three
to start with makes a lot of sense I
guess he's following it up with like a
rook fc1 and at some point I like the
idea of 91 and opening up my Bishop
um he plays Bishop F1 actually that's uh
intriguing in fact I mean light squares
are weak but I guess you can't really
get to them with the pieces that you
have he takes with the King
I mean just a provocative style today
very provocative but nothing you can do
about it pretty solid huh oh yeah I mean
don't get me started like that last game
when he castled writes I mean just
straight into the attack absolutely
ridiculous how he got away but this time
I mean key on F1 it is there but not a
lot of Firepower for black where you
could try and exploit it
he plays the queen B5 move attacking the
Knight keeping some pressure on the C5
pawn queen of C7 played King G2 nice
little move tuck and roll there this is
a 3-1 portion I forgot you have to move
so much faster like transitioning is
sometimes hard especially even when
you're down you know transitioning from
five one to three one you have to go
through faster now and you're down right
so it is more difficult I think it's a
huge as the time gets faster your car
gets it's better right it's kind of
scary so so scary yeah I mean we can
both definitely speak from our own
personal experience
um playing these SEC formats and yeah it
always takes me a while to sort of
settle into each time until like from
five to three and from three to one you
just have to keep up that Tempo
absolutely you have to keep up with that
Tempo here and of course Hikaru does
this every day day in and day out
usually playing three three one five one
I mean I'm playing in the title Tuesdays
playing a both of them eight hour
streaming at the same time so it's
difficult to compete with that sometimes
if you're not you know doing the same
amount of playing you see he has 29 30
000 games you know what I mean in the
system there that's insane that's just
yeah right you don't get up there for
for nothing yeah it's not work I think
you can break here with E4
um
oh B4 Queen A4 he has he's got Queen A4
here yeah yeah he definitely missed that
and I think he I think he debated David
into it and now he might win a pawn
six
Rook D6 I take you go see
maybe you have a little something
something going on there I mean no I
don't I don't yeah night before I don't
think so Rook before but maybe
yeah Rook D6 CB4 C3 is interesting
it's very interesting C3 with C2 ideas
but David he's got to come up with
something I mean letting his side wind
down exactly
fast minute here or under uh sorry A
Downing minute I also be under one
minute as well three minute one second
increment here you think he's still in a
five minute mode I can feel that right
now
yeah he's just nah I got a lot of time
even if he somehow gets out of trouble
yeah when with such low time like you're
just gonna
basically get right back in it so right
we've tried this way
same idea
is there oh B5 there's cd2 and and the
B1 Rook can hang in some lines
35 cd2 yeah yeah like Rich's X Queen C6
oh he's playing he's gonna go for it
anyway yeah I mean I guess at the end of
the day it would be queen against two
Rooks
Knight D2
92. whoa whoa whoa holy smokes wait a
second here
wow
that's a cheeky little Intermezzo so now
at least he gets rid of one more Pawn
still though
cd292 like still pawned down not out of
the woods by any stretch of the
imagination
take
I takes D2
I like this Pawn from Hikaru here three
four three four
all right we got the extra Pawn Yeah you
can try to convert that's just tough man
I mean you playing great chess David
like man it's tough facing this guy five
oh and Rook C6 another great restricting
move I think he can play
even a simple move like yeah I like Rook
bc1 I like Knight F32 but also H3 just
so you can meet H4 G4 and that's a T4
yeah that looks classy he plays it too
look at that
base 4g4
and then Knight F3 there's Queen E4 but
rookie one so I'm good to go
uh bricks hanging so maybe Rook C1 oh
takes push oh it takes and push we gotta
be careful there's nice loose it is
loose but I don't see a way to take
advantage like that night will hop right
back to F3 our D4 guard your king and
there's just no way through for black
okay he pushes it Queen D3 I think I go
B7 yeah I'm in time there so you have to
deal with that and and then I can I have
a free hand to play a knight of three or
what I want whoa are you subtle yeah and
play it and now we need to figure out
what to do with the Rook obviously
the defend well it works C2 all right
he's going for broke
so if he Queens Rook D2 queen of four
one
oh there's Queen V1 there which I
blundered okay but Queen D Queen D2
though oh Queen D2 yeah yeah Queen E2
taste Cherry come on get him off the
board that's a resi
there it is surgical Precision yet again
for mikaru
and now another different response okay
but this transposed into something
normal or not he just wants to play
stupid stuff today huh I guess
he's having a good time he's laughing
F5 he's having a good time right having
a good time enjoying it
just playing whatever he wants today
but we need a we actually need account
because I know that he hasn't played the
same thing twice for black
so if I'm doing my math straight there's
15 games
which means that he's this is his eighth
different response to 184 wow whoa okay
95. five yeah
he like yo you're gonna stop
disrespecting me like this bro
I like it but if Carl
doesn't seem to be impressed just yet
after Knight G6 there is Knight F6 I was
just thinking that and then what do we
do now Bishop F7 oh there might be a
bishop seven but can you have seven oh
95 that's mate and then Queen F7 that's
mate right
yeah oh the puzzle Rush
oh you know I do that every day oh every
day baby United States version of seven
is gross
but let's see uh so why is this not just
completely toasted like so you get away
with HG HD Queen you can't play that
what is this yeah you might have to just
take it which he does
Queen g16 D7 yeah Queen F5 there's key
eight
oh you have kinky hey get out of here oh
it doesn't that's so annoying man
if he finds a way to survive this then I
mean there's just not much you can do
yeah you're right yeah take on deep
spots like yeah this is nothing you can
really do take on D5
yeah 97 I'm trying to calculate their
Force wins for white or not yet
foreign
anything E7
right yeah I think queen of seven would
allow black uh
yeah
we have five key EA Queen G4 K8 as well
seems like there's nothing better than
the Civil Bishop D5 right yeah it's a D5
he goes Queen F7 the one thing I mean
the one thing I don't like is you give
black so many different options right
there's literally four pieces that can
block on E7
yeah interested best move was Bishop D5
and then playing Bishop G5 right over
half so really just developing to get
your piece back and natural removal
Bishop G5
it was just crossing now it's zeros but
let's see can you just block away
anything yeah every move he IG Knight D
to E7 is the only move that loses oh
okay I think it's just like you can
block with anything else
okay can you play another Like Queenie
Queenie eight wow yeah you see that in
the Dutch in the uh the bishop G5 Dutch
with f65 very early that's funny Queen
E8 and King d8
so the funny thing is Queen E6 he ate
your queen would be under attack
Bishop under attack and the uh this
bishop is still hanging yeah so I would
have to repeat their
um do you have anything better like
Bishop B6 check King C6 that King's
starting to run
wow
I mean what's a what a provocative day
from Hikaru what if we go D5 after that
oh yeah there is a defect maybe just
keep running though King B6 yeah he just
runs away what on Earth bro there's no
[__] you gotta be kidding me can I not
can I win yeah I mean can I get a game
I'm telling you a car he car really
could be Invincible
can I get a game bro my his King on B6
Jeff his King's on B6 yeah he's gonna
try to take in Queen F4 Maybe
oh my goodness okay double attack we
need three check
uh
the car is still laughing like let me
tell you if I had my keynote B6 I would
not be laughing yeah King on V6 just not
a care in the world
so if we need threes there's C5
this is nuts
wow and it takes oh my goodness
dude this was still hanging I don't have
anything developed who's better here
right check C5 blade opposite The
Bishop's hanging and there's a B2
problem very strange very strange the
Rick's hanging there actually King C6
Queen E4 might be good for what that's
cute that's cute that's a check what do
you do he takes meaning four anyway King
seven Queen F4 I guess you're just
kidding bro you keep going up and down
like a yo-yo yeah you can't go to d8 you
just have to go back to C6
this is hilarious being on C6
wow but it is four pawns for white so it
should be good like what if I just take
on C8 at some point and now quiz for a
check not sure what this accomplishes
Castle nope it doesn't work it doesn't
work rookie six and still not quite yeah
you covered d67 rookie six this is
exactly what about Bishop witchcraft oh
Bishop C8 Queen E5 checked 25 check
exists yeah this this is some type of
voodoo's type stuff he'd be you know in
here bro this doesn't make any sense
Queen E5 checking it well you can't even
beat him like he's King's on C6 bro stop
it you gotta be kidding me I guess key
F1 would prepare rookie one right you go
like 25 check Camp when Knight takes
C8
yeah
and let me see a rick takes mini five
though yeah I think we're gonna see it
yeah
Queen B5 well I mean I don't really want
to trade yeah you got three passers bro
yeah I guess the end game would be good
for white I got three of them boys I'm
not mad like I'm not mad chick
you wanna draw bro I'll take it like I
think you've got to get your Rook on
each one involved somehow like with h
work H3 but suddenly when Knight D6
comes
oh yes yeah that's a great way to
describe Scrappy this is so Scrappy
Scrappy rice Scrappy yeah there's a a
Carol Khan pinup baphunic lion with a
knight D6 Grisha psac they played
against vide gurjarati with the white
pieces but I think a car is doing well
now like Rook have four points there's
Knights before it is okay not anymore
yeah this is this is terrible just take
on B2 yeah I've got Rook D4 look at the
time Jeffrey Rook D4 oh yeah he's got no
time I just realized geez 94 in there
he's not going to survive this
okay C3 is a good attempt though forcing
the Queens off
94 94. oh
he even managed to win this I mean I
can't believe it bro
can't believe it he was getting crushed
and David refused several uh draw offers
in this game oh it might be one there's
there's the finish washing touch it
hurts yeah that definitely hurts bro I
was rooting for David in that game too
that hurts man A35
he's just trying whatever maybe before
back to this I think he played C4 he's
also played E4
um
yeah no freaking way that's exactly what
I was thinking incredible
this is some type of Vienna with an
early A3
yeah that A3 Pawn push basically useless
though because I don't see any way that
can ever benefit you
but he's probably gonna make it work
completely useless movable because it's
correct I mean usually you have the same
position with the pawn on A2 in the
Vienna with the early Bishops YouTube
the problem A3 literally did nothing at
all for you
it's kind of funny but D3 yeah okay
Bishop E3 I like this H4 H4 Alpha
zero-like approach from David
maybe you go Queen G5 yep King D2 I know
it's a crazy mode but oh no that's right
up at cars alley I mean
he's gonna put his key on B6 yeah
I'm playing this kind of Chess today
anyway yeah I need his last one yeah you
should all right what's the most
disrespectful move I can play that's
what he's probably thinking what is the
craziest thing I can do king D2 let's do
it
I like Queen F1 as for some reason I
like the queen yeah Queen F1 and at some
point I like GH4 opening The Rook with a
rookie oh there's a cheeky little trick
here with GH4 and if black recaptures
with a record Knight Bishop C6
G4 say my similar idea yes similar
that's nice watch out don't block with
your face 986 Ace 3D
yeah I like Knight D6 keep the Knight
centralized but after age three
how is this so solid okay Bishop V6 and
castles
yeah really I can't move anything though
like this looks like a sicilian Right In
Reverse with black some type of I don't
know dragon or night or for something
where the king is in the center here I
can guarantee you hikaru's thinking
about playing like C4 and King C3
King E1 but all right he's he's uh going
gonna play sane for once
E4 attacking A7
King V8 but now that just closed let me
look at this bishop that might have been
a weird one yeah positioning this is bad
but yeah
yo yo what's Queen C1 I think one and
Bishop three yeah I like this I like
this queen c one yeah that was Queen B
one but Queen C1 just makes sense Queen
D1 doesn't really make that much sense
King D2 King E1 King F2
yeah he just having fun he's just having
fun bro but F5 is going to be big
H5
yeah no now it's now or never go F5
take on E5 FG
what is this
there's Knight F4 though to cut off the
f file okay King looking crazy right in
the middle of the street here of course
obviously uh what do we have Rook check
what is it Jeffrey G3 Rook check if G3
keeps G1 and the king would find itself
surprisingly safe
we do Rook check wow it's minus four
maybe we just no
it's like check and take maybe we'd have
seven it takes yeah
just or yeah I don't know queen of Fate
might not be the right Square I don't
know how exactly you do this it's so
tricky
yeah and now he's off
gs36 doesn't work I just want to see
real quick what did he play he took and
then yeah
yeah it's Queen F7
GH3 yeah F7 G3 but in the game I mean it
curves back in it it should be seven in
here like there is some such tactics do
exist
yeah I mean David has to resolve the pin
somehow I don't know if you go Rook H6
Rook E8 but worst case scenario hikara
can play the end game now and he's safe
yeah rugby one's really strong but I
like Rook B1 too
very strong move because even if you
move the king I potentially could still
sacrifice
but I have to be accurate has to be
right
but Rook B1 King CA then I'd be happy to
take on E6 with your diagonal ah correct
correct yeah I was just taking a six
you have a very annoying moment I'm
wondering if we should be seven but
yeah
I mean David's not gonna be able to win
this bishop D7 blade
it's a good move
I guess you could just take on E7 play
Knight C6 that's one option
because just trade everything down try
to believe oh but there's also Queen D5
and if C6 Knight C6 right engine did not
like this what why this is why not
exactly right what are you talking about
what are you doing rookie seven is yeah
let me see what they think because this
is a great move
play C6 take everything and Rook Ace to
G8 because he has no mate oh wow that's
crazy C6 let him take everything and
play Rick Case G8 yeah and then I mean
David might be forced to find that
though at least he might be fighting he
might be forced
whoa no Queenie one no but this doesn't
work I taken key F2
I mean he's fighting for a draw Still I
can go here and trap tonight in D2 King
C7 or this oh yeah Knight C3 maybe your
night Michael but can you do Knight B1
oh it might be one correct maybe nasty
so annoying C4 so what do we do go to D1
I think it would be one anyway okay Rook
C8 but Bishop A4 now he's gonna lose
this
C4
yeah he's gonna lose this one as well
two passers by square bishop and that
Knight is stuck on the side
oh that Rook now controlling the third
rank King C1 Unstoppable
H4
easy pickup
easy game here one second for David this
is not looking good at all so rough no I
mean nothing's going David's way even
when it was Winnie I mean he got
provocative openings I mean like
positions were great especially that
last game
it just couldn't compare all right he's
content with the Rook against the Knight
which yeah it should be
should be more than enough
let's see with the extra Pawn checking
up C3 restrict
very nice walk to King up
good stuff
yeah okay C5 that's it resignation
oh man I mean got he played King D2 King
he won King F2 and he's still once yeah
it's crazy he still won
still this is the most normal we've seen
out of his opening well maybe he did
have Ellie again and like yeah he's back
to I mean this is one of his favorites
playing that modern little tiger uh
appearance with A6
we see this all the time in the title
Tuesdays
indeed we do and Knight D7 yeah he's
gonna go for probably a setup with
Bishop B7 double fee and keto not quite
a hippo because he'll probably play
Knight F6
but close C2 castles probably
he might actually play a hippo with e697
quite annoying quite annoying setup the
hippos are especially against strong
players like Hikaru it's like you know
he's just trying to attack and you do
get good positions in fact but you have
to convert Bishop H6 love it whoa yeah
he's giving up the E Pawn but I guess he
would have like a queen or something
impression on the efell exactly Knight
G5 yeah
like this because now once black gets an
E5 it's transfers into sort of Spanish
and
maybe yeah maybe Carl solved his
problems here
yeah he's already good I mean block
eight here very nice star Square Bishop
Khan but of course white does have his
chances as well maybe even trying H4 H5
G3 moving the Knight F4 F5
yeah you gotta try something on the king
side but 957 I like this probably going
around to B6 and forcing your hand uh
with the pawn on A4
yeah the very Spanish like like you
mentioned here Spanish Roy Lopez
definitely very Spanish language C2 as
well some type of Briar right here
exactly yeah car was at a Crossroads
there he didn't really want to play H5
and allow the Knight to jump in so he's
willing to go Knight F6 back I mean
white did weaken some squares there on
G4
I'm a big fan of Knight H2 just trying
to open up some lines lovely news active
but I think you have to watch well F4 we
can take with the queen yeah we can take
back the queen it's gonna be a great
move actually
yeah car is going to take his time here
I see he's lean back very relaxed very
chill his nice CDC preparing 10 games
preparing I guess after F4 he wants to
take in
either maybe Queen B6 or put something
on E5 yeah
yeah five
but actually F4 Queen V6 he might just
wanna I'll trade him off really still
the game rough yeah it's gonna be really
annoying maybe A5 then but that does
create a weakness immediately I do I did
like A5 because now once you allow Queen
B6
the queen has to relegate itself it's
gonna take a long time for you to get in
this F4 plan I have to go King H1 now
and F4 you're not gonna be in time at
all E4 thing also Knight D3 He also has
this and this one
so I mean you gotta go Bishop C2 for
starters
I feel now he's Frozen
but I mean as you mentioned earlier that
pawn is always a weakness
so now yeah I like Bishop C8
King H1 now I'm playing F4
annoying oh my goodness he probably
plays everything you can never get
anything you can ever you simply can't
G3 the night coming into D3 although
wait there is a B4 move it's like g393
393 B4 that's nice so he goes back so
maybe we tuck and row and try to play F4
bro like come on bro Queen G2 F4 makes a
lot of sense yeah otherwise black at
some point is going to play uh on the
queen said with rupee 8 and B4 at some
point
yeah that's gonna be annoying definitely
Knight to G4 what is this move where are
you going what's the idea Jeffrey yes he
wants to put on E3 I don't see why else
yeah correct and maybe he's back to here
in F4 I guess finally
oh there's also a 93 Knight F5 in there
aha which is why Carl got rid of it
immediately
there's that Rook p8
F4 King G2 prophylaxis do you like
you're not ready to push F4 ever because
I'll take and activate my rook and then
I'll flick in my B4 move both Rooks
would be heavily in the game looks like
he's going to G4 now yeah now you now
again F4 is just no longer an idea so
David's shifting his eyes over to the
queen side
only break is B4 B3 not really feasible
yeah you just you left with the backward
C Pawn yeah it's like he's defending
which is he's got to sit tight yeah
there's not much you can do
it's tough
Knight G4 provoking F3 one more weakness
required to try and probe
I hate it night back to F6 you're going
to go Knight H6 and F5 is the question
that's very active if I go F6 yeah I
guess he's just about to F6 but that was
a very nice idea
really no reason to play too
recreationally for a car I mean ten
point lead last game in the three minute
I mean you can just do it do what he
wants right going into the bullet where
I mean you know Hikaru is a heavy
favorite their highest rated bullet
player on chess.com it's very scary to
even face him so I think his chances
were definitely in a five and a three we
didn't get our shots there but of course
can't count David Out steal there's a
match left the bullet portion definitely
is in Caro's favor it's tough
yeah now calculating whether or not
there's the right moment to push before
he says not yet
and he's going to switch his forces
again to the king so that's what the
good players do they play on all sides
of the board that's correct he plays
Rick fa with the F5 himself sword of
King's indian-esque but uh the king is
on G7 here
now Knight F6 is a huge thread that D5
Pawn is is a dead duck it's just going
to be falling like a house of cards
we could just double the Rooks here
double or do you play yeah I think
you're just double
okay oh he's gonna switch to this is
some stuff maybe Quincy five yeah just
play the end game yeah shut it down
right it's a very very safe way like
he's still got two more breaks uh in
mind he's got G5 in the future and he's
also got the B4 idea once you trade
Queens
we just get him off I put the 90 C5
beautiful
you've got a
[Music]
I mean he's just classic and says how do
you defend you don't and then I bring
the Knight back around to the to the C5
square and David's been he's been
playing these last 20 moves man on the
increment just
too tough for a cafe ATM G5 now I think
you opened the other side
how about that how about that
yeah G4 doesn't really accomplish
anything it's all over here with B4
that's a nice move that's a nice move we
have B3
I'm not sure if you go B3 you just take
an A3 yeah take an A3 I thought the same
and then beat well oh no he sticks
tonight on B3 that ends all counter play
right
on a time there black wins wow I mean
the score astronomical here 11 point
lead going into the bullet that's tough
very very tough Jeffrey uh as we take a
look at this Jeffrey this card right
here Jeff as you see it is all in Hikaru
it's been a Karu show here maybe was
able to strike back here and there a few
times but it's just not enough as in a
smarter chest looks like they're right
too they could predict a seven and seven
and I think just half off there's a half
off seven and a half one and a half very
very close I mean David I think he
actually had a a brief lead in the
three-man portion I'm not mistaken like
one and a half half but a car rattling
off six game six games in a row blows it
out I mean that's why you don't poke the
bear I guess yeah I don't poke the Bear
right or hey Carlos
yeah it covers uh helped the Bear right
you want to help the bear if you're
facing Hikaru in that situation it's
pretty tough of course guys
um but yeah so as we get back in touch
that we have some stuff for you so get
ready for the December 2022 state of
chess.com coming to you live on December
21st we have some huge news for the
chess community and the event will be
followed by a Community Q and A plus
some very special guests will be joining
the show talk about the exciting
announcement and what it means for the
future of Chess and the chess Community
don't miss the show December 21st at 10
A.M Pacific right here on chess
twitch.tv chess all right so let me see
how there for that chat where it says we
got to take a short break we'll get back
to the bullet portion and uh we'll keep
it going from here so we'll be right
back in a few
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move a pawn
to the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples under promotion as we said is
the process of promoting a pawn but not
to the most obvious or most powerful
type of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a knight that
move comes with chet on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately chromic would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop underboarding
to a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the a4ea diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop F7 first and there
is no way to prevent Checkmate on the
next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
guys we are back with a bullet portion
of course at the speed Chess
Championship Jeffrey there's been a lot
of Chess and it's been a show here with
Hikaru where it's uh just doing a
domination scene for everyone here as uh
it's just amazing right we see from
Chicago Jeffrey what's going on
yeah 11 Point Gap it's ballooned
completely
um match
nearly out of hand I mean you can still
play 11 games in the bullet but I think
there's a lot of reason to watch here
Hikaru known online as maybe the best
bullet player of all time
um at least for one plus zero so yeah
we're still gonna witness some really
beautiful artistic uh Majestic play from
from the car himself and we have 30
minutes here now this is not the real
bullet what I mean by that is of course
you get that one second increment but
that one second goes very fast and he's
going with his trusty Knight F3 B3 I
actually got a over to board win Jeffrey
probably the greatest game I've played
besides beating the GM and last Turner
but I had this this imip like very fast
H4 H5 nasty attack and I was very nicely
credited to what I've learned from ikaru
playing this 903 B3 system oh yeah stuff
I mean look at this right look how
awesome oh but how about that idea by
David leaving his Knight undefended here
obviously you have six Bishop F6 would
be a skewer right so a little nice
little tactic thereby by David
the Knight to C3 here Castle Queen side
this is I mean if you can get these are
aggressive positions believe it or not
the reverse Queen's Indian Rook to D2
politics E5 is a huge blunder here we
have to figure out what to do now we can
take on E5 yeah Knight C7 and I hated
that move wow I guess Queen E3 okay that
makes sense H3 G4
yeah it could be you could smell it
before and why it has it takes you can
draw the position but okay what what is
going on yeah this is a problem after
Bishop takes takes you have Queen D4 in
many cases due to the dark Square
control
this is just a strategically one I'm not
even gonna lie to you Jeffrey this is
already over for white it's very rough I
mean from the files here you do have 96
but this is hanging too like look at
this man what is this yeah you might
have to move like 98 seconds
all right a night on E8 man it's right
it's a rough day in the office Bishop
c4h3g4f5 very strong stuff
and now I think play G4 right now yeah
he doesn't even need to take that pawn
on D6 yeah it's very nice keeping full
control position here Queen D4 Queen all
right hitting the ninth can't play King
G7 you just be in a pin for eternity
so I guess you have to play yeah Queen
d8 but d a and G4 is definitely moved
but you have H3 might be just takes very
easy yeah just cashier just takes it
says
and rookie seven
will be the follow-up
so it's all I think that's just all you
all she wrote
rookie seven
you know rookie seven and takes and
takes
oh man look at this I think just Rook C6
yeah
and then this is a wrap Bishop F7
beautiful Ricky six oh we could just
take and take yes take everything
everything take everything right
brutal now take everything during the
break actually as Hikaru likely wraps
this one up I just wanted to say I wrote
down all of the car's responses so far
24. he's up to nine he's played E6 C6 G6
D5 C5 A5 Knight of the royalties now and
Knight C6 yeah I wrote it down just to
make sure that he was trying to explain
different moves but I think did he
played G6 there so that's our first
repeat uh of a move one response and
Jeffy roads is down Jeffrey wrote him
down I mean I was curious like I really
thought he would try to play all 16 like
different move one responses to 24. my
goodness
it's a clinic today bro it's a clinic
yeah I like this for a car too yeah yeah
very topical lime usually you like to
play G4 Roman Genji has really has some
very nice lines with G4 and not castling
actually Quest and queen side that is
like an early G4 because the pawn is on
F5 with the idea to open the G file here
Blackstone is really nice
yeah you could set up a pawn Diamond
here if you want with F5 and E6 but
there's no real need to do that I think
queen of five swing that Rook over to G6
start playing on the king side right
yeah I Like It Here pawn takes you have
to have Rook H3 B5 that's nice oh first
fix for Queen side entirely
okay after it's nice though he opens the
E file open up take this swing yeah
there we go there we go
six
still nice and solid for both sides
maybe white just plays something like
rookie two Bishop D2 guards ponche now
he goes Bishop B5
slightly concerned though about about
that C3 weakness
five here that's slightly better he is
yeah Rook C1 maybe you can go Rook C4
you can at some point start penetrating
on the AFL with rookie Rook A2 he's
trying it that's exactly what he's going
for okay hey where K2 calls it B3 B
through it and here maybe black can
consider B3 at some point no he just
takes he just takes yeah and Rook B3 and
then I guess okay for fourth yeah at
some point I like Rook A4 and you start
hunting down White's King
yeah we just we're just shuffling we
just shuffled back and forth here five
still oh there's a
still nothing I guess I mean I guess
King could just dropped back to E3 yeah
I tried this one unfortunately white has
a very safe Niche with the King on F4 so
you couldn't really
um harass uh with the Rooks behind
yeah David's keeping Pace on the clock
which is important I think you should be
able to draw this game
yeah should be and of course uh oh wait
wait wait 16 seconds yeah yeah now you
should be starting to slow down a bit
it's getting concerning just like how do
you even get real play here um
right exactly
is rookie seven anyway Heaven should be
fine what oh he's gonna try to play hey
my guy you better oh no you wouldn't
check first
and a nice way to nice way to wait wait
wait is there E6 wait yeah I was just
thinking that was there an E6 there
might have I I guess if her could have
kept that pawn at base so right right
likely we see a drawers there's still
chances all right maybe Rook C4 check
but uh for her card here
otherwise Rook C1 and King F5
we also have yeah can you have five wait
a second he's winning he got five and
Rook G1 and King F6 yeah maybe I guess
yeah
that's it all right nice win for David
let's go David let's go A4 A5 now he's
saying it wow so fast
before all right I see you in the car
come on bro H5 H4
yeah we're gonna I think we're gonna see
quite a few outlandish opening tries
these next few games
we have already at least so it's a G5
let's go David
let's go and this is like terrible like
God I can't play this and I don't know I
was gonna try this but he just gives up
the planet D5 yeah that's not that's not
how does the curve get this kind of
position when he starts out with a5c
through B4 that's not even going that's
what I don't understand whoa oh oh can't
do Quincy five nice captain
Nice Shot there he's he's looking now
David looking I like it I guess Queen D5
you'll take an E4 he's got good control
of the center oh very nice E4 yes and
you get away with ed4 just keep sacking
Sheen about it
84 does it it's on the board it's on the
board here now I guess I just take on F6
though no if you take on C6 I thought
I'd take on yeah take on C3
what's this I mean Wicked what yeah the
point is Bishop three Queen C6 you can't
take on it's a rook cause I got the fork
oh I oh The Rook is also hanging yeah
boy in price here but she does have a
knight of three and then Queen H3 though
he's out wow he's actually out of there
yeah those lines are working for black I
think this should be good Carl not very
happy with himself but still a really
sharp position well he's not happy with
himself I play A4 like that hey Cara not
happy with the opening bro you play A4
B4 C3 yeah he has a very good player
engine two a knight of three I'm gonna
try this his head what about C2 okay C2
I guess Knight bd2 it's not so simple
for black
um maybe you go Knight E4
yeah 94 is really strong then it is 94
with Knight G5 intentions very strong
you know maybe could go no Knight d2s
now we're living on the edge
right that's a good move
um I think you have to keep Queens on
though Queen E6 I like this rookie one
instantly play Rook c86 let's get those
Rooks in the game
yeah
Knight A3 uh rookie a makes a lot of
sense at some point I think you want to
push C2 maybe now uh Rick C4 oh black
Black's winning oh oh nature
combinations what's the is there some
age yeah we missed something two seconds
here for David he's got no time just
gotta trust his instincts now
looking for rookie three
oh there's also rookie two is huge
rookie two is nasty you play King F1
because of it
Queen everything everything drops back
to everything let's go big David
David out here Jack can we call it a
comeback probably not but at the same
time I mean hey let's get some energy
right let's get some energy whoa Bishop
two is that a slip oh Bishop D3 is the
main move there but definitely
I mean Community Ford is a good way to
improvise
C5 Queen E5 check wait Queen what is
this E5 what is this
yo look at hikaru's face Queen F4
yeah it's starting to slip maybe
slightly careless there from the card
that's that's why he hasn't been playing
uh these e45 actual Theory this is what
he knew it would lead to yeah right you
know do we call this a comeback or not
chat do we call this a comeback
this is three in a row where did this
comeback he's winning in the bullet
portion he's winning right now in the
bullet portion
G6 well it's still not over maybe oh I
think you can just Castle now yep we
need two queen H6 is mate
so we have to defend the pawn how do we
do this maybe here here and here so
Bishop F4 Bishop B5 oh that's one way to
do it yeah and you literally don't even
care about anything oh yeah four no no
Bishop four takes it you go rookie one
then Queen H6 and then oh rookie one
yeah that would have worked beautiful
beautiful I guess David doesn't really
see the need to take extensive risks
yeah he needs to be quick though he
needs to be very quick I mean yeah
who always finds a way to find chances
it feels like so annoying like how does
he sneaked out a little piece of
movement you little dirty dog you should
I say [__] Page Six that's so annoying
Bishop D6 Bishop F4 preserve eight try
to get it off the board no keep chasing
Bishop penetrate you try to get it on no
trades Ricky won Bishop F4 and I was
really strong I need to develop the
business yeah Bishop F5 correct this is
still not that easy I mean what is the
podcast he's got only one Pawn but like
the Knight on C3 is limited he's also
running the clock I mean he's there's oh
my God down to 10 seconds oh man if he
can't win this it's brutal
take on E2 he did win two in a row 92 oh
that's a good move Rook E1 uh terrible
to make oh no C1 oh man chances equal
it's slipping yeah and then that's
losing it should be three and Bishop E2
Queen H6 what a queen F6
but then E2 hangs at least ah you're
right you're actually right so maybe we
just take yeah okay oh Queen A6 Bishop
fate yeah that's more precise oh yeah
yeah oh this is insane Queen F6 is here
after wait I mean oh yeah you can't
takes takes
oh my gosh
he's down a piece he's not a piece he
was down a clean piece for nothing
with an attack but it still wasn't
enough against the car yeah yeah I mean
he went two in a row like you know he he
bouncing back Queen D2 Queen yeah ice is
it
yeah yeah there it is
and that would have been three in a row
and I feel like Dave is going to go on
tilt now and probably probably uh
just unravel entirely I'm sure he felt
it I'm sure he felt a comeback though
he's like oh one all right cool two I'm
doing it third game winning like you
really are like okay maybe I could do
this thing
or make this you know a little bit
better but F4 now is another opening
throwing one more in for us he loves a
reverse he loves the Leningrad the
reverse Leningrad exactly and will he
play an h4h5 I'm wondering
is that is a typical idea you can try
here I love playing this movies for H5
Bishop D3 just sacking everything and
mating
David thinking I mean you got it there
it is
and now if H I think there's F5
or white
yeah oh H5 F5 oh my goodness that's
gross just breaking up the whole thing's
gross F5 I like oh G4 he does it in
another fashion yeah
yeah
I mean
the engine still thinks that black is
doing well here for some reason they
like let me see oh Knight what
Jeffrey Knight F6 oh my goodness that is
disgusting oh I gotta show that that is
wrapped on G5 and it takes and takes
like yo what a concept sick that is sick
but I mean I still would I would like
white but like wow just not the fact
that that's a thing that's sick yeah but
in the game I mean he's got an H5 now
96.
what is this Knight takes C5 197 Knight
F3 Queen takes F3 oh yeah so well
calculated
nasty stuff nice hanging take those
which pawns you take and oh there's also
Queen D2 which I like a lot I love this
move a lot but I mean queen G6 I guess
so he just took the bishop D ah yeah
Queen G6 probably for black
I mean D5
yeah you can just snatch that pawn so
again Queen D2 We need two queen G6 and
Bishop D3 Bishop five I guess uh yeah so
he went this route instead do I have I
mean how can I get this like there it is
but Queen G6 whoa I mean there is some
counter play here for Dave what oh
this two this two everything easy easy I
mean I mean it's made everywhere right
it's got to be
in a million years oh Bishop C4
after that Hikaru game where his King
was on B6 you know anything can happen
Bishop check
E6 check oh man oh man all pre-moved all
this oh my god oh get that off the
screen bro
I'm gonna have to watch the fight for
that one okay wow that's not can you put
that on the screen again h4h5 Knight D5
oh this is this Theory actually
serious is
still looks okay this looks nice for
Dave you go Bishop G5 no he takes
maybe some saxony6 could be in in the
air
oh and this should be five yeah very
very good position for David
yeah so get out the way
like Bishop G7 and 95 is an idea yeah
I'm visiting yeah I mean this is I mean
David where he's like working him he's
like working him right now that's what
it feels like whoa the car just ignores
it
and if B3 you weaken your position there
could be like a knight landing on C3 in
the near future
that's gonna be a little nice little
reroute to the house
exactly and I rookie this is just simply
good again this end game Trading
uh
yeah rugby two rookie two he's counting
on
would be two e double
okay David
C4 that's a nice little Discovery he
opens with the bishop and also hitting
this which is connected to your Bishop
be very careful where you step there
could be some night before ideas that
I'm calculating like cd5 Knight beasts
like rookies is this a bluff or does
zacaro have something
I have a feeling he's gonna pre-move a
bunch of moves again
he actually has to take some tastes and
then pushes yeah
yeah well he does it he does it with the
A2 idea and Knight C2 oh my goodness but
it's not made crazy yeah the bishop is
giving up the material though you give
up material good move Guardian C2 now if
A2 knights2 is just gonna sack and push
the d-pawn yep oh my goodness very nice
plan Rook B8 oh but there's uh there's
night uh what is there I thought there
was something yeah it is good it's so
strong like it covers everything Rook B8
is completely losing I like this I mean
it's literally why is it losing though I
have no idea in fact I mean I have nasty
discoveries it just says push the pawn
that's it and believe it or not what
nothing I can't believe this either I
guess this bishop is like the best
bishop ever oh wherever you jump with
the night my king goes to the other
direction always defend it I'm like
always offended yeah everything easy I'm
always offended
it's like and if your car is in
disbelief yeah right
right there's nothing here I would be
too like how can you not be in this
building look at this position that's
too can you see one
there's nothing unless some type of swim
wait why King A2
that is oh
look at me oh come on get him off the
board oh I'm done I'm done I'm out oh my
God that is hard you on your own bro I'm
out I have a good one all right see ya
James
no man that is ridiculous oh my goodness
oh he's gone the other way he was safe
he had gone the other way not the only
way to self-made how did you do that
how oh man I'm tilt I'm done I'm done
I'm done with the match I'm done I'm out
I'm out of here bro I'm out of here bro
I can't win that I can't win that I
can't win that Jeffrey
Jeffrey I can't win that one all right
okay cool cool
bro cool
yeah I think C5 here got to cut off
Knight D4
the benign Last Knight D4 now he's just
he's on till I mean there's really no
other way to put it
oh my goodness
oh man that hurt that one like stinks it
does someone just stains you still sums
up it sums it up sums up this match
uh yeah it sounds like to match that
right that is just Wicked Man completely
losing
and hung made the only way to hang paint
King takes A3
now okay Carl's gonna sack a Pawn on E5
but he's saying that he has permanent
control of all the dark squares after A5
I do like it I like it he's gonna step
up to E3 oh yeah yeah A7 singing
E3 first G7 I think you can pick off
Jesus yeah G7 and now obviously called
the Bishops oh I love this move from
David C5 is good beautiful move I wanted
to go back but now I can't I was like
excellent G4 don't play Rook G5 Rook D5
C4 or Rook D2 and I'm like who's winning
I mean we got the opposite colors taking
Rook B1 after last games you can't put
anything past anything no not at all and
the car is just playing like lightning
still 50 seconds here of hp5
guess he's going Rook if he won what's
up coordinate in the chat Ricardo style
right here
typical typical Lucario now can you just
take on C4 and go Rook B4 yeah cut him
off
Rook D5 Maybe
just don't blunder another me that's all
I'm asking it's kind of it's either said
it done right it's hurt hurt after that
you like you know the pieces don't even
look this way why do I feel like
something's coming yeah no no what but
it does I mean you guys you got hit like
that man it shocks you like you still
feel that two games three seconds
Rook h1o Ring Around the Rosie here ah
this is scary again
goodbye dagger we're K5 I
okay it hurts hit him everywhere hit him
everywhere
oh man what's the other one G6 G7 okay
yes first king D2 Rook C1 or oh No Just
G7 anyway yeah resignation
another one oh so painful
wow what was the smarter chest again the
prediction was 22.
it was 20. we're getting close to that
it wasn't 22 to six yeah I think it was
22. it really finished 22-6
dang that's crazy smart attest might be
right this time
crazy yeah 22-6 that's crazy
22-6 it's been on point wow
all right this is another car special
doubled F pawns but it's got a nice
solid structure there it's pressure on
D4
F5 is going to be uh the move at some
point is to say that this is my only
weak Pawn which would be F7
but I do like I do like the pawn A5 you
restrict and now start pressuring along
the B file C3 nice move consolidate
good play from David
we'll put some pressure on the B file
too
yeah and also kind of strong after Rook
B1 Rook B8 there might be a D5 idea
there uh opening up your Bishop
oh D5 E5 yeah right opening up to Bishop
yeah
does it work
E5 you take maybe maybe not the best two
but it's possible right yeah
he's gonna calculate it
you can also just play things slow here
maybe like bring the Knight around
H4 King very patient yeah all the moves
you have to make right all the waiting
moves
it's King G2 why not
let's do it yeah Hikaru is stuck here
you can't touch the bishop ooh Aces
three
yeah kh3 just stopped me any F4 now the
knights goes but ah Bishop d8
I like 92 but you're right Bishop F4 is
kind of annoying and also uh the pawns
hanging F4 wow oh if gf4 he's gonna go
Knight G7
you know this
still very good for David I don't know
if you want 95 or yeah he's gonna put
the key on F3 play Knight C5 maybe C1
first
but I don't think you were so worried
about rooksy too just joking F3 here
I get one you get one we trading
everything out
tactics
this has been a really sharp game from
David
start to do your puzzle right nice David
very nice
a car in a think tank there he does not
expect that
I'm not sure who's gonna be able to get
out of this one
how do you deal with this you just well
he's gonna pick up if he's getting the
pawns oh that's very very nice
wait a second still not easy maybe Rook
B7 Rook D7 and then Rook B7 yes that's
good that's very good that's very good
yeah okay okay Bishop B6 still
not the easiest conversion five seconds
he has to move
outside a clean on a dark Square aha
he's got Rook C7 yeah this is a clinical
way oh okay seven a bit slow player okay
six E6 F3
F5 though blade can get four
who's like he's making a slight mess but
it's still okay
no draw
so yeah this should be good although the
car is going to win H4
most time is left five minutes yeah
there's no way he's coming back he's
like he's a 14 games in a row here
that's the tough yeah
and now the question is can you even win
this position
very hard to say I mean Bishop D6
Hindi five
played
what is he doing he jumped off the deep
end chat on National Television there it
is oh wow somebody get him get you a boy
wow he just dropped the whole [__] all
right that was that's a way to convert
it might regret but not I mean
definitely not a big deal not gonna
haunt him yeah yeah definitely
he definitely uh
hung a whole a whole Bishop there the
whole thing
in ic3
yeah he played Knight C3 Knight B1
Knight back to C3 early Bishop E3 next
just finished the development very nice
Bishop's a G1 at some point if we need
to oh he just said C6 restrict your
pieces
takes Knight F3 okay
short on Spaces like it is yeah you got
to watch out I guess nh5 there's still
Queen G4 yeah
yeah H3 slowly build everything up
okay
you know something's wrong Knight G5 is
GG
no no no uh E5 E6 E5 right you're right
E5 oh yeah this allows H6 so still
saving grace yeah Knight G5 here E5 and
G4 in the tween strap yeah and if Queen
D6 E5 E6 yes oh yeah Queenie five E6
right E6 I mean it's nasty pretty nasty
stuff but this is good as I mean like
he's uh six at some point you'll you'll
prep F5 like you probably maybe even now
you could consider that you prepare it
first yeah H through G4 you've also got
94 ideas well like 94 and ic5 yeah yucks
yikes D5 not playable five is desperate
interesting practical attacks but still
just 94 solves the problem is B4 maybe
E4 is good also Rook C1 it's also on
Knight D4 but I just take this pressure
I go A3 ah there is Knight D4 you have
to be worried about okay
wait why didn't he go V6 I thought he
wanted E6 there all right and now he
there it is E6 now Rook C2
it's consolidating I'm up a lot of time
yeah black has total control over the D5
now so it's okay
um totally fine for black probably just
you can exchange Queens whenever he
wants with Queen E4
making G2 yeah Rook c2s keep everything
under control wait Rook D4
almost wraps the queen but yeah I was
like wait where do we go yeah yeah only
two squares for the queen there close
Rook takes D7 maybe just right walk the
king over go to E3 E4
E6 nice move plant that Bishop on C5 and
play B4
ah G5 is also good that's a good move
that's a good move for the king E5 a
weakness but probably still balance my
best play
it was only a minute 40 left here looks
like Hikaru is going to be advancing
guys he is going to be advancing
um so yeah as we as we see here let's
see what the number is going to be for
smart chest so they did put it at 22.
if they uh
probably you won't get the 22.
notice I'm dancing here watch out Rook
G8
tricky though
okay good play much better in a bullet
but this is unpleasant akara might win
this with your king Knights yeah because
it's the tricky Knights right like it's
the worst position you want to be in
David has no time either
is gonna dance
oh Bishop H2 is nice though in King G5
oh that's nice hey who's in this looks
wrong close to this one H4
actually David might be winning all
right that's good that's some good Zuck
there maybe not a very weird it might be
Knight of four or or this or yeah yeah
this oh just wrap it out rep it out okay
I'm Gonna Keep playing I mean he might
try to bleed the entire match clock out
but it's difficult to avoid this
repetition
oh but now he can
yeah don't blunder a fork
he does not Knight D6 take that no that
was losing
okay King E4
F4
are you shaking hands bro
yeah Kara just gonna bleed this entire
match
out we're probably gonna see our final
game
oh G5 kh5 great move
I think if anyone has chances it's
probably black still those pawns look
loose
the time issue is huge there's Bishop uh
King G4 yeah it's still okay
checking Knight C6 now the knights out
pH five oh the car is slowly making
progress but it's still a draw
[Music]
and that is official the match clock is
up
because he's advancing
yes I mean a dominating performance
from the get-go
so trying to make something happen here
I mean right the clock gotta be careful
wait he loses the g-pawn
but it's still fine it's still actually
fine because your opponent E5 handles
both E and F
um no but now no no what is this can I
take F5 oh yeah is this not winning
how can this not be winning
oh because oh Freddy's idea Reddy's idea
oh my goodness how is he in time there
it feels like with nine lives that's
nuts bro study yo in games oh my
goodness that was already's idea that's
a and he found it in seconds though
that's insane he did yeah I mean David
careless slipped there at the end
haha
it hurts
oh man
that's crazy
all right yeah doesn't really need to
play on the match clock expiring but
just to be certain
that's it
that's it he Carol laughs there and that
is a wrap Now smarter trust was wrong
there they did not get the 22 and a half
they were right about the six piece from
David six and a half in fact akaru is
gonna Advance there as he is the winner
of today's SCC match chat what do you
think about that right there Jeffrey
what do you think about this whole match
it was a lot of fun um definitely
entertaining us with his opening
uh early on basically everything he
could as black and also his white
obviously the A3 H3 dynamic duo it was a
lot of fun um wish that David could have
taken more advantage of some chances uh
punish occurred's provocative play but
in any case the better player does go
through
oh yeah absolutely of course uh Hikaru
just didn't dominate it when he came he
did what he came to do and he dominated
as usual as you guys said as well by the
way we are going to have an interview
with the big fella himself you know oh
we just heard there is no interview
there was no interview okay no interview
okay we just got the word okay
uh no interview chat but
um with that being said of course uh
Hikaru moves on as we take a look at the
bracket here as we take a look at the
bracket we got Hikaru playing LeBron
oronian I call him LeBron aronian
because he is just like that as strong
as he is but we got to live on Iranian
versus Hikaru Nakamura as you see there
we got ding Lorraine versus nihal sarin
you know Carlson versus Carolina that's
a world championship SCC right there nut
stuff you got Wesley so versus MBO lots
of SCC chess coming up it's gonna be
amazing and the next match check the
next match is actually going to be uh I
think Dean Lauren placing facing nihal
sarin
um tomorrow in fact yeah tomorrow so
Jeffrey I mean what do you got oh my
today's match was nice look at this one
too
non-stop action this is the prime of
Chess I feel like I mean we've also got
women's candidates running alongside
this got the chest boxing over the
weekend this didn't amazing time to be a
chess fan yeah absolutely amazing time
to be a chess fan fat uh chat I mean is
absolutely amazing you guys are pretty
awesome and uh before we go here
actually
um is there any chess player in your
life
um who you would like to receive a
premium membership to chess.com do you
have a holiday party tonight but totally
forgot to buy a present this holiday
season share the beauty of chess with
your loved ones whether you plan ahead
or find yourself in a Time Scramble for
a last-minute gift chess.com has the
answer buy a gift membership for the
friends and the family come on now drop
command gift in the chat for more
information chat so some holidays of
course for the holiday season Jeffrey's
been amazing it's been fire it's been
awesome so much chess today I learned
some stuff myself here that I'm gonna
Implement in my own game so I don't know
about you Jeffrey and chat but it's been
awesome today bro
yes sir A3 and H3 it was so much fun GM
candy uh looking forward to seeing more
of you both over the board and on stream
big fan and I will see you all next time
of course chat of course stick around
for the raid and there will be some big
shows tomorrow huge show tomorrow with
Dean Lauren anyhow stars make sure you
guys are there I start to say 6 a.m
Pacific time and uh you know we'll see
you guys when it happens it's gonna be
commentary with Daniel near Disney and
Levy in the Chevy Levy Rosman you know
what it is all right chat love you guys
wish you guys uh follow our channels too
I'm at GM Canty and Jeffrey's G mjx it's
been a pleasure we'll see you guys on
the next event
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]